I've built multiple 10 million dollar
plus companies I don't know how to do
anything I don't have any web
development skills I don't have video
editing skills I don't have design
skills I don't have any skills I can
write all right I can write books and I
can speak but that's it I'm an
organizing Force I'm the guy who just
organizes it what you're about to hear
is a round two interview between me and
the incredible Daniel Priestly now
Daniel is actually one of the most
popular episodes that we have ever had
of the podcast and the first episode
that we did which was around a year ago
still continues to get thousands and
thousands of views every single day in
this episode we talk specifically about
how to go from 0 to 10K a month as an
entrepreneur and then we talk a bit
about how to go from 10K to 100K a month
and then we talk a little bit about how
to go from 100K a month to a million
dollars a month as an entrepreneur 10
grand is not a lot to certain people if
you've already got a half a million
pound business a half a million dollar
business 10 Grands okay yeah we can do
that and we're going to be talking about
a bunch of Frameworks that you can learn
and apply to whatever stage of the
business career you're at we're going to
talk about the four different types of
products including the Eiffel Tower
metaphor and throughout the episode we
Riff on a bunch of different business
ideas and we apply the principles to
these ideas kind of in real time so you
can see how they apply in a real world
context anyone who can run a pub can run
your business a pub has drunk people and
people like hooking up and having
relationships a pub is like got razor
thin margins you just do not need to be
running your business that's not what
you're good at as a key person of
influence you should be out there doing
the thing that only you can do oh by the
way if you have a couple of minutes I
would love it if you could possibly fill
in a little survey we are surveying the
audience people who watch or listen to
this podcast and trying to figure out
what are the things you Vibe with what
are the things you don't who are the
sorts of guests that you'd like to see
more of and what sort of topics should
we continue covering on the Deep Life
podcast so if you've got a couple of
minutes it would mean a lot there's a
link in the video description or in the
show notes would love it if you could
help us out and help us make the podcast
better for you guys so yeah check it out
Daniel welcome back to the podcast it's
good to be back this is sick like you
are one of the high most viewed episodes
of all time and if we sort of excluded
the people who are already like like
super celebrities you are the most
viewed episode of all time I'm totally
stoked about this this is incredible
what do you think landed so much with
people from the previous time you came
on on the podcast I think we just went
through a journey and we hit a whole
bunch of bases I'm hoping we can deliver
as much value today as well yeah um and
also here's the other thing I think
everyone's interested in becoming an
entrepreneur
um the world has changed so much in the
last 10 20 years and the rules that many
people grew up with have changed the
schooling system is preparing people for
a world that doesn't really exist for
you know as far as many people see
there's a lot of people who are
dissatisfied with the game of work
because it doesn't pay enough
um and the conditions aren't good enough
and it doesn't feel like it's giving you
enough freedom and flexibility and you
know something that's going to be
exciting and interesting and engaging
and a lot of people are turning to
entrepreneurship and they want to know
how to do it nice so we're going to be
talking about how to do it in this
episode we're going to go over the
entrepreneur Journey from zero to 10K a
month 10 to 100K a month and then 100K
to 1 million a month no pressure and
we'll split up the other podcast into
these three chunks and we'll try and
just sort of Blitz through as many of
the Frameworks and ways and the
philosophies and the ways of thinking
about it as we can love it so that
people can at least know what the
roadmap looks like and then they can
fill in the gaps with specific
implementation based on other reading
and other resources and things like that
here's the thing I want to say up front
um a lot of people think that
entrepreneurship is a really
unpredictable Road they think that it's
uh you know dangerous and risky and all
of those sorts of things I've got an
analogy that I think is worth saying
right up front
um so as you know I've got three little
kids a four-year-old a five-year-old and
an eight-year-old so we do lots and lots
of Lego
so imagine you you start with this Lego
box and you look at the front of the box
and on the front of the box is the
picture of what it should look like at
the end and then you tip the Legos on
the carpet it's a big mess and you go
how do I get from that mess to that box
and then there's a little set of
instructions that says do this then this
then this and it breaks it down just
step by step by step and then you don't
have to really think if you just simply
do the steps very rapidly it starts
looking like the front of the box now
entrepreneurship is actually very
similar to that there are a series of
steps and you go step by step by step by
step and then it starts looking like the
front of the Box pretty quickly so
that's what I want to cover today I want
to like basically try and demystify it a
little bit I want to take all the kind
of weird risky kind of misconceptions
out of Entrepreneurship okay but surely
this is too good to be true I've heard
that like you know entrepreneurship is
like you know 99 of startups fail or
whatever that number is I know so many
people who've bought a course on day
trading trying to make money online and
like they're they've just failed and
seems like the only people getting
ritual for this are the people selling
the courses yeah so what's what's going
on there okay so great great uh first
frame the first thing I'd say is
entrepreneurship and trading are very
very different right so trading is a
zero-sum game you're buying and selling
equities or you're buying and selling a
financial instrument and these are
zero-sum games there's winners and
losers and there's nothing in between or
there's brokers in between but you can't
value add you can't buy some shares or
some currencies and value add those you
have to basically trade those and try
and get in and get out at the right time
the reality is because it's a winner and
loser sport something like trading
um
you are not going to beat the winners
right so the people who are the best in
the world it would be as silly for for
me to go into the NBA and say that I'm
going to try and score a few points
against the professional basketballers I
could try for 10 years I wouldn't score
eight point not one
um because they're professionals they're
they're built for it and they're like
paid crazy amounts of money so that's
who you're up against when you're in the
trading space so entrepreneurship is not
trading that that is definitely not the
case
um when we go into the world of
Entrepreneurship you can value ad and
you can do all of those sorts of things
why is it that
um it's not uh more predictable for most
people well for starters
entrepreneurship
you're figuring out what the market
wants and most Market needs already met
there's already businesses there's
millions of businesses yeah so most
Market needs are already met
um and people it's like yeah I already
have a company that makes great um
cupcakes I don't need another Cupcake
Company
um so the thing is is that we're trying
to go through a process of discovery to
find something that is an unmet need
something that the marketplace wants but
doesn't actually have access to and that
is hard right so it's not that it's easy
but there are a series of steps that
allow you to de-risk it and to Dey
mystify it and to not over commit not
you know take yourself into a position
of of being throwing money at something
that's not going to work okay that makes
sense
um before we get into the I guess the
entrepreneurial Journey um you know
you've written a book called how to
raise entrepreneurial kids and you have
some thoughts about the school system
and kind of
how how we got here I wonder if you can
just sort of Riff on that for a moment
like why is entrepreneurship so alien to
the way that most of us were educated
yeah so entrepreneurship feels very
counter to The Way We Were educated
because the education system was created
in the Industrial Age when they had to
create something called component labor
component labor was creating
um nicely machined parts that fit into
somebody else's organization someone
else's machine if you think about the
world prior to the digital Revolution
you had local economies and you
basically graduated school and had to
fit into a local economy so some kids
were going to grow up and become local
police officers and some were going to
become local doctors and nurses and some
are going to become local teachers and
some are going to be butchers Bakers and
Candlestick makers so all the things
that were in that local environment and
you essentially had to graduate school
and then fit into a business that was
already up and running and established
in the local environment so the model
for schooling was to create component
labor people who fit nicely into other
people's businesses where we're at right
now is very different
so the world that we live in right now
is teams that are geographically spaced
out
um business opportunities that could be
incredibly narrow and Niche but a mile
deep customer base that's all over the
world
um and you can in that environment you
can actually be very different you can
be highly creative you can be Innovative
you can be
um exclusive you can be specialized uh
all of those sorts of things so it's a
very different environment in the
digital age the next thing that I would
say that's different is that when you're
an entrepreneur you're looking at a
problem that exists and you're trying to
come up with a solution that fits that
problem when you've come out of a school
system you're developing a skill set and
you're trying to find an employer that
needs those skills so nice slightly
different yeah
so when when we think about like
um a Porsche 911
Porsche 911 they don't say what are we
good at and they go okay we're really
good at making the chassis of the car
but we don't do tires and we don't do
stereo systems so we're just going to
sell the thing that we're good at they
say what does the customer want well the
customer wants to be able to drive the
car straight off the dealership and feel
great about their purchase and to do
that they need tires and they need a
stereo system in the car so what Porsche
does is they ask what does the customer
actually want what's the experience
they're looking for and how do we bring
together everything that's required for
that to happen so they say okay let's
get Pirelli tires on there and let's get
a Bose stereo system in there and let's
get two and a half thousand suppliers
and let's pull them bring them all
together so what businesses do is they
find a solution to what the customer
wants what employees do and especially
when you've come out of school is they
have skills and they try and Market the
skills to an employer so these are
slightly different they sound similar
but they're they're quite different and
that's why entrepreneurship feels a
little bit different when you move from
employment into entrepreneurship nice
and how do you define entrepreneurship
so entrepreneurship is a couple of
things number one you are trying to do
something that commercially is
successful you want to make money right
so let's not beat around the bush
entrepreneur a big part of
Entrepreneurship is you want to make
money you're doing something for
commercial success it's it's not
a charity
um you're trying to make a profit the
next thing is you're taking a risk so
entrepreneurship has an element of risk
um and normally it's even it's a risk
for the entrepreneur you're in some way
risking your time without a certain
outcome or you're risking money or
you're risking someone else's money
um you're you're doing all of those
sorts of things
um and the next thing you're doing is
you're organizing the resources beyond
your own control right so you're
starting with limited resources and then
you're expanding your sphere of
influence over resources so when we
think about those three things if you
weren't really taking a risk you'd just
be a leader or an asset manager
um if you
weren't trying to make money you might
be a change maker you might be a
positive force in the world but you're
not an entrepreneur right so it has to
combine all of those elements and when
you say uh what was that thing you said
sort of organizing resources so if you
had all the resources right let's say
you're a trust fund kid you've got
millions and millions of pounds already
that your dollars that you're starting
with and you've got all these people and
it's it's all there you're essentially
you're a leader you're leading the money
or your asset managing an entrepreneur
is normally someone who's accessing
resources beyond their control so they
have to enroll other people to join
their team they have to enroll investors
to put money in they have to enroll
customers to buy something that isn't
really proven so you're kind of
influencing people outside of your
current sphere
and how would you define entrepreneur
versus solopreneur
you know a thing that's become popular
recently on Twitter and like one person
businesses and things like that yeah
so you're still commercial you're you're
still taking a risk you're not really
organizing a lot of human labor you're
not organizing
um people outside of your control I'm
not a big fan of solopreneur and the
reason for that is because if you're a
quote-unquote solopreneur you're
basically
if you go on holiday the whole business
goes on holiday and you can imagine what
it would be like if Microsoft said
everybody's on holiday this month we're
all going away at the same time right
Microsoft would shut down and it would
like the stock price would crash so
if you're a solopreneur and everyone
goes away all at once uh which is you
um then that's a very precarious
position and the truth is you never
really switch off as a solopreneur so
what you're trying to do is you're
trying to like create something and sell
something and deal with customers and
all this sort of stuff all on your own
and the truth is as soon as it starts
showing sign of working why wouldn't you
have a salesperson why wouldn't you have
an assistant why wouldn't you have
someone who's you know customer service
role why wouldn't you start bringing
together a few people to make this thing
actually a proper business and to also
specialize your own time on the most
high value thing that you do I mean
people famously say oh I don't want to
manage people
well I think managing people is when you
go past
in some cases six or seven people
sometimes you can manage up to like 12
um but certainly once you go past 12 you
are into management teams and all that
sort of stuff and it's it gets hairier
and more complex let's just call it 10
people so under 10 people you normally
find that you're a self-organizing team
think about it like a dinner party
if you have six or seven people around
for a dinner party it really does
self-organize people just like get their
own drinks and they like bring things to
the table and everything kind of works
and it's kind of a flowing conversation
if you go over 10 11 12 people 13 people
now it's kind of like you've you're
organizing people and you really the
stress comes on and it's like guys it's
time to sit down to the table over here
now and who's got the drinks and who's
doing this have we got enough food so
suddenly it's like a it's a much more
complex production to bring that many
people together so there's something
magical that happens which is a
self-organizing little team certainly
three four five six seven eight people
eight people you're definitely a
self-organizing little team there's not
a lot of managing people
um in in that okay nice cool so um
apologies for taking us on a little bit
of attention down that route but I know
that people you know are interested in
the whole sort of situation
um so
0 to 10K a month that's like our first
step of the process
um and so I wonder if you know this is
something we tried on a previous podcast
if we can sort of pretend to be coaching
me as a beginner to entrepreneurship I
don't really know anything about
entrepreneurship but I like the idea
sure I've maybe listened to you on Deep
dive without and I'm like oh this down
in Priestly guys knows what he's talking
about I would like to engage his
Services as a coach I know you don't
really do one-on-one coaching anymore
but like how how would we approach that
conversation if I were say
working a full-time job as a junior
doctor two years out of med school and I
want to start a business but like I
don't I don't really know what's next so
I love a good framework and my framework
for this would be chaos chaos stands for
concept audience offer sales so concept
is we need to come up with something
that is a good idea a good concept when
people say Ali what on Earth are you
doing why are you quitting your job to
do this thing they're going to say what
are you what is it you're going to do
what are you going to start so the first
thing is you've got to have a good
answer to that so you've got to have a
concept so let's talk about concept
um and I want to do this nice and quick
but do it justice yeah so the first
thing that I want to do with the concept
is I want to know do you want a
lifestyle business or a performance
business right what are we building what
does that mean so lifestyle business is
going to be
are we keeping it small so that you can
have fun freedom and flexibility is that
the purpose do you want to just travel
and work and
um and have a little you know gang of
people that are you know Rebels and
misfits and we keep it small and
deliberately the whole purpose is fun
Freedom flexibility and especially we
don't want debt or investors right so
that would be a lifestyle business
lifestyle Boutique and
um the second thing would be a
performance business which is we're
building something to sell it we want to
become big and valuable we want to be 50
million 100 million plus in valuation we
want 50 employees we're happy to take on
investors we want investors we want debt
we want to build something that's going
to be valuable so the first thing I'd
want to know is do you want a lifestyle
business or do you want a performance
business I think of it like a property
developer with a block of land do you
want to put your dream home on the block
of land or do you want to build a
10-story building and sell it
um like a property development okay I
want to make if I could make 3K a month
that and that that will allow me to quit
my job and then I'll be happy so it
sounds like a lifestyle the beginnings
of a lifestyle Boutique right so and
this is not a bad place to start
normally a performance business is
something that you would do
um if you've got really good guidance
and and you know you might have it might
be your second time through so um that
would be the first thing the next thing
I'm looking at is what we call omv
Orange origin story mission and vision
so what is your background and we need
to do something that lines up with your
background there's no point where we
don't have any passions or any you know
like when you talked about trading
before I see people they watch some
trading videos online and then they're
like oh I'm going to be a Trader why
well because so and so said that I could
end up with a helicopter okay amazing
um and it's like what about your
background says trading nothing you know
you've never done you're not analytical
you're not you don't have any of the
kind of background that a trading firm
would want to see in a Trader that they
hire none of that's there you've just
seen something you think money so
there's no origin story whereas let's
look at you you became a you know
amazing YouTuber but your background was
teaching people you were
um helping you know Cambridge you were
talking to people about how to um you
had one of your first businesses
teaching people how to you know study
for exams so there is actually a
background there you also were
passionate about media and you were
doing stuff in the media space so you
had a bit of origin story that was
leading up to this so what would that
look like for someone who maybe like
I've spoken to a lot of people who would
say oh but I don't have anything I'm
passionate about like I'm studying
insert generic degree at Insurgent Eric
University and in the evenings I go home
and watch Netflix and scroll social
media and hang out with my friends like
uh what in in that context how how do we
approach talking to that person about
this origin story if I had time with
that person I would discover that around
age 10 there were moments where there
were the early moments of empowerment
now I've worked with enough
entrepreneurs to discover the that
always around age 10 to 13. there was a
moment where you discovered that you
were actually independently powerful
separate to your parents
um and you have a moment of like
wow okay
you know what I'm not just a dumb kid
I've actually there's something going on
here so you might have stood up to a
bully you might have
um taken ownership of something you
might have you know put together a
little play something like that so
there's always clues in that
um and psychologically one thing I've
found about entrepreneurs is that
they're at a very deep level they're
trying to get back to that feeling that
feeling of empowerment and it started
early so let me ask you the question
around age 10 to 13 do you remember a
particular early memory where it was
like I had a moment of empowerment I had
a moment that feels like wow I'm I'm on
my own and I'm actually a powerful
individual yeah it was when I started to
learn to code coding yeah and when I
started making websites and the The Joy
um I'm kind of getting emotional for
like even just talking about it just the
joy of creating something without my
mom's permission and like just making
the thing and then started like
advertising my services on a freelancer
website back back in the day so there's
some elements here of Technology and
there's some elements of putting stuff
out to the world like you're actually
creating something and putting it out to
the world
um and there's elements of like no
permission right now if we go and fast
forward to YouTube it's a no permission
platform you're creating something for
the world and you're putting it out
there in the world so there's all these
kind of Echoes of that early memory um
so what happens is that this ingrains in
this pretty early and everyone's got one
right so we all have a moment sometimes
it's a negative experience so sometimes
um like a silly example the origin story
for Batman is he's a victim of crime his
parents are killed and he realizes that
he is on his own right he has to figure
it out real fast on his own that he's
now a 10 year old kid who's orphaned
right so that's his origin story and he
has to wake up one day and say I'm gonna
work with this situation that I'm in
right so that is his moment of
empowerment I know it's a fictional
story but it resonates and it's a story
that stood the test of time but it's a
good origin story example that everyone
relates to so sometimes it's negative as
in like something bad happens and you
have to just face it yeah and in many
cases it's very positive I had one I was
10 years old
um and I hosted my own garage sale so um
we had some stuff in the house that was
damaged we had a little kitchen fire and
it damaged some stuff and I decided to
clean it and sell it and one of the
things was a microwave and this guy
comes up to me at the garage sale and he
says um how much for the microwave and I
say twenty dollars
he says can I talk to your dad I say oh
okay I must have done something wrong so
I go and get Dad and dad comes out and
he says um what what's the problem and
he says well your son says the
microwave's 20 but will you take fifteen
dollars and dad looks at him and he says
well it's his business
you'll have to negotiate with him hmm
and I just in that moment just went whoa
It's my business you'll have to
negotiate with me so here's this adult
and he looks at me like embarrassed yeah
and he says oh uh can I give you 15 and
I'm like no it's 20.
so in that moment I'm feeling incredibly
like empowered and I heard this word
called business and it's my business and
I started an entrepreneurial venture I
took something that was a negative which
was a little house fire or something got
damaged I cleaned it I fixed it I sold
it I made money I ended up with a green
bicycle and Sega Master System so for me
this was like whoa you can take bad
situations and through this thing called
business you can make it into good
things
um so that was my moment of empowerment
and it's no surprise that I ended up as
a serial entrepreneur and so we're
saying that the concept for your
business should ideally be linked to
some sort of origin story when you try
and do things purely to make money right
money is a part of it right money is a
big part of it when you try and do
things purely to make money it never
works
it just doesn't work
um everyone who makes money whether it's
Warren Buffett or some amazing hedge
fund manager my goodness it runs deep in
their veins there's something about it
they're not just they're not just trying
to make money they're trying to get back
to a certain feeling nice there's
something in there that's uh that needs
to be unpacked so what would you say for
someone who's listening to this and
thinking damn you know 10 to 13 I don't
really have anything I was just like
hanging out with my friends TBH you
might be an NPC
uh look honestly if you're really that
stuck yeah entrepreneurship is an
advanced strategy you need to go and
work for an entrepreneur you need to go
and do six months with this company six
months with this company you need to go
fishing around
um this is not like entrepreneurship is
not some Ticket To Riches
entrepreneurship is a really good ticket
to be stressed all the time to sit up
late thinking about your business to get
really freaked out about where the
customers like stuff or not
um you know entrepreneurship is is an
advanced move it's something that you
should do
but you should actually be an
entrepreneur begrudgingly you should go
there's this thing that has to happen in
the world no one's doing it I'm gonna do
it right but it's not you know it's a
bumpy road that ends smooth it's not a
smooth Road it's not for everyone it's
not for everyone
um and there are six million businesses
already in the UK there's 30 million
plus in the in the USA go join one go
and join a team stop trying to get a job
at Goldman Sachs where you're going to
be shoved in a corner and you're not
going to know how that business runs or
what you know who makes the decisions or
where things come from go work with a
team of eight people
find out how they make the sales get to
know how they generate leads get to know
you know what do you do when a customer
is upset about you right how do you
handle a customer complaint go and work
in a small business start working side
by side with entrepreneurs and if you
can work for an entrepreneur for six
months to two years and you go actually
I could do this and I've got an idea
that's that's the thing so
I'm not going to try and tell someone if
you're struggling with this just keep
pushing through maybe you're just not
ready
this episode is very kindly brought to
you by heal I've been using hula I've
been a pain customer of huel since 2017
since my fifth year of medical school
when I first discovered it and basically
what it is if you haven't heard of it is
that it is a meal in a shake it got the
perfect balance of carbs and fiber and
proteins and fat and it contains 26
different vitamins and minerals all you
do is add water or milk to the powder
usually I use water you can shake it up
or you can blend it I prefer to blend
and then it becomes a fantastic option
if you're like me and you're kind of
busy and so you don't really have time
for breakfast or lunch my favorite
version is the heel black edition it's
absolutely sick 400 calories 40 grams of
protein for 400 calories I'm trying to
get hinge and it's actually pretty hard
to find something that has such a high
protein content for such a low calorie
trade-off and so I really like using the
heel black edition to start my mornings
off it's vegan it's gluten-free it's
lactose free the Black Edition is
available in nine flavors my favorite is
salted caramel and I wouldn't recommend
having every single meal heal because
that gets a bit annoying after a while
but it's absolutely fantastic it's like
one of the meals of the day especially
if you're busy and you're gonna kind of
default to something unhealthy otherwise
it's also very affordable so it actually
works out to one pound 68 per meal for a
400 calorie meal which is just
incredible value and actually way
cheaper than other generic protein
shakes on the market and it saves a
bunch of time because it's so quick and
easy to make and so it's particularly
exciting that they're sponsoring the
podcast and actually we have the founder
of huel Julian Hearn who was on the very
first season of the podcast that was a
sick episode that got so many rave
reviews as well anyway if you're
interested in trying out huel then head
over to huel.com forward slash Deep dive
and if you use that URL a it really
helps me out but B you also get a free
t-shirt and also a free Shaker that
comes with your order so go to heal.com
forward slash Deep dive that'll also be
linked down in the video description or
the show notes and thank you so much
heal for sponsoring this episode this
episode is very kindly brought to you by
trading212. now people ask me all the
time for advice about investing because
I've made a bunch of videos about it on
the YouTube channel and my advice for
most people is generally invest in Broad
stock market index funds which is
exactly what you can do completely for
free with trading 212. it's a great app
that lets you trade stocks and funds and
ETFs and foreign exchange if you really
want to and one of the great things
about the app is that that if you're new
to the world of investing you can
actually invest with fake money you
don't have to put real money in they've
got a practice mode where you invest
fake money and then it actually tracks
what the market is doing in real time so
you can see had I invested 100 pounds
into this thing what would my return
have been X weeks or X months further
down the line once you've got some
comfort with that then it's super easy
to deposit money into your trading tube
into account you can use Apple pay like
I do initially or you can use a direct
bank transfer and then once the money is
in your trading 212 account then you can
invest it in basically whatever you want
now if you're based in the UK you might
be familiar with the concept of an Isa
which is an individual savings account
which is basically a tax-free wrapper
that you can put money in you can put 20
000 pounds in every year up to twenty
thousand pounds and it resets every
April and then all that money can grow
and it's completely tax-free for the
rest of your life and if you want to
sign up for an iso you can sign up for
one completely for free also on trading
212. so if you haven't yet filled up
your eyes allowance or at least put some
money into your Isa for this year that
might be a good step forward also very
excitingly there's a new feature that
they've added to the app which is a
daily interest on your uninvested cash
these interest rates may go up or down
over time as the economic environment
changes but the cool thing is that you
get paid out every single day if you're
into that sort of thing the app also
lets you Auto invest which is a great
thing because then you can automatically
invest a percentage of your paycheck
into the thing every month and so if you
haven't yet started with investing and
you want to give it a go then you can
download the app on the App Store and if
you use the coupon code La Ali it will
give you a totally free share worth up
to 100 pounds it's available on iPhone
and Android and you can check it out by
typing in trading two one two into your
respective App Store so thank you so
much trading212 for sponsoring this
episode okay so let's say my my origin
story was age 10 to 13 I made I made a
few quid uh playing guitar
busking on the street and people give me
money and then I recorded a CD of cover
songs and I sold it for five pounds here
and there and age 13 to 16 I was playing
gigs in local bars and stuff and making
a few quid there is that the a potential
origin for a potentially entrepreneurial
Journey it's certainly An Origin story
there are there are literal elements to
that there are also just emotional
elements to that story so there's
performing in front of people being the
star of the show there's creating a
physical product and being out there
selling it so there's those elements
that that can also play a role it
doesn't literally have to be that you
have to be a musician but it could be
that you want to work in that space what
we're trying to do and we're really
early on right so we're just having a
look at basically we're just having a
look at origin mission and vision so
origin is what's your background vision
is what would you love to see happen in
the future what do you what do you know
what do you see happening like
um lifestyle or performance business you
know do you see yourself selling this
business do you see like what what is
the exciting element what do you want to
do for the world so all that's in the
vision okay and Mission
is what is the most high value thing
that you can do right now so mission is
um like in World War II uh the vision
was to defeat the fascists and the
mission was to storm the beaches so you
can see that there's a big Vision this
is the end result that we're looking for
and today today this is what has to be
done or this is the thing that is most
important so in business a vision is
where do we want to get to and a mission
is what is our high value thing
so for me my mission is develop
entrepreneurs who Stand Out scale up and
make positive impacts in the world and
if I wake up and do that mission then
there's a pretty good chance I'm
delivering high value hmm
right so that we start with we start
with those basics
let's make it more practical right it's
all philosophical at this point so
practically you then want to ideate you
want to come up with 10 Concepts
um you want to look at what problems can
you solve
um and who's willing to pay the most for
those problems so it's really important
that we combine those other other
elements a lot of people are very hung
up on passion but there's two other
elements of a good concept and that is
that you're solving a problem in the
world and that people are paying for
that problem okay so here's the
unfortunate truth when it comes to any
problem in the world there are people
who throw their time at the problem in
order to solve it and there are people
who've got loads of money and they want
to throw money at the problem to solve
it and if you want to run a great
business you need to talk to people
who've got money to throw at the problem
so yeah this is the issue I often find
with students in that the only Market
they know is students and students
famously do not enjoy throwing money at
a problem they throw a time at problems
yeah and then they're like oh why why is
my business struggling yeah it's like
because you're trying to appeal to
students yeah exactly exactly you're
trying to get Market uh you you're
trying to appeal to a market that loves
to spend time on stuff they're not they
got no money to throw at it right um
whereas if you simply had three clients
who were multi-millionaires and you were
solving some sort of problem for them uh
you know you'd make loads of money hmm
how does one go about
finding ideas is it a case of you lock
yourself in a room with you and your
buddies and you're like think of some
business ideas or what's the you come up
with 10 ideas and you pick the best
three
okay
yep and you go and then you test them
and you test them as fast and as cheap
as you possibly can so you're looking
for an idea where you push the door and
people respond Push the door and it
opens you're not you're not trying like
I hate how people think
entrepreneurship's really hard it is
really hard but it's hard the good types
of businesses are hard because there's
too much to do and not enough time so
like that the hard problem that you want
to have is there's too many people who
want this and I can't keep up with them
um you know I've got 40 people to call
back today and I don't have time to call
back all 40 people that's the problem
you want that's a good kind of hard yes
you don't want to have a problem that's
like oh this is like no one's interested
yeah the bat so I remember when I was um
in my third year of uni I was the
president of the Pakistan society and we
had a ball um like a charity ball every
year and it was such an absolute
nightmare trying to sell tickets for
this ball because we were selling 35
pound tickets to students who did not
have any money who 35 pounds a lot it
was a lot of money I was really like oh
like it felt so like hard because it's
like there was no demand for this and it
was like having to message Facebook
message people that knew other
universities to be like guys you're
gonna love this event it's really fun
and like in the back of my mind I knew
that like it's a lot of money these guys
don't have money it's it's not gonna be
that good objectively but like having to
be a sort of snake or salesman in that
context
um I hope no one from the packs of days
is listening to this but I really felt
like I was a snake oil salesman and that
gave me a real sense of uh when I came
to trying to sell that
whereas when we open the door for our
YouTuber Academy suddenly oh crap we've
got more more demand than we even know
what to do with yeah one of the one of
the great questions is like does this
product deliver someone a return like
what's the return on investment for them
and if there's if there's like a ten to
one if you can think about a ten to one
return it normally is going to be a good
people are going to pay for it yeah so
um YouTuber Academy clearly is worth ten
to one all right if I start a YouTube
channel
um and it succeeds I'm going to earn
money I've got sponsorship opportunities
I'm going to build a personal brand it's
going to create digital assets that last
forever there's all these positives that
could easily be defined as a ten to one
ratio so whatever I spend there's a
great return and it's nice and clear
that there's a there's a nice return so
um a lot of good products you can
actually explain how it Returns what
what is the return on this product and
there's a there's a quite a clear
imbalance hmm okay so coming back to our
idea thing generating 10 ideas so what
does an idea look like at this stage is
it like a A3 business plan or is it like
a tweet or like what makes a business
idea a concept so yeah it's probably a
page of notes about the idea in the in
the early stages so we're going to talk
about what's the product going to look
like who might it be for
um those sorts of things but then pretty
quickly we want to test it so I've got
three ways that I like to test ideas I
like to run an intro event which is
purely and simply just an introduction
to blank
um I like to run a quiz which is
um uh are you ready to blank answer 10
questions and find out on score app so
um and I like to do a WhatsApp group so
yeah WhatsApp group is like um so
WhatsApp group is like
um for example if I was going to do the
Pakistan ball I would say we're thinking
about doing a um a Pakistan ball all the
tickets will be released in this
WhatsApp group would you like to join
the free WhatsApp group and get early
access to tickets
so it's like just purely and simply if I
can get people to join the WhatsApp
group yep I'll give you a real life
example A friend of mine Max he wanted
to create a product for what's called a
family office a family office is a very
high net worth family who employs people
to manage their money full-time all
right yeah exactly it's a yeah the
people who've got so much money they
need to have a full-time money manager
so
um he wanted to put together a group of
people who do that who are family office
managers
and what he did is he started a WhatsApp
group and he basically said I'm putting
together a WhatsApp group for people
whose families
um Family office managers hundreds of
millions and um and it's a place for you
to talk to other people who run family
offices so you put together a WhatsApp
group and immediately he got about 19
people joined and that was the beginning
of a very successful business how did he
know these 19 people he reached out to
them yeah
message them on LinkedIn I'm launching a
family office group I've got this
company who've already agreed to come
and join would you would you like access
to my um my my group
um and people sure because here's the
thing it's like well I can always leave
like it's a WhatsApp group so who cares
but it's a really good first test hmm
um I know someone who did a clinic a
fertility clinic and they created a
pop-up WhatsApp group
um five days to better fertility
awareness
um and it was basically a five-day
pop-up group uh joined the group and
it's basically looking at research and
um uh what's called Miner and macro
markers or something like that and it
basically helps people to have five days
to better fertility understanding and
fertility awareness and I think four or
five hundred people joined it so yeah
so quizzes WhatsApp groups and events
okay Zoom events free events online
things so let's say my business idea was
I want to I I really enjoy making
Burgers I want to make one of those
Burger Vans and go into Cambridge town
center and sell my Burgers okay for
starters please don't do food oh okay
it's one of those Capital intensive hard
to scale businesses
um it's normally a recipe to lose money
um for Burger not good well look if you
want to use it as an example we can use
it as an example but I would almost
instantly rule it out because it's
Capital intent okay I'm gonna throw some
more examples at you and perishable
you're dealing with a perishable product
um allergies uh food safety requirements
and also it doesn't really scale like if
you want to serve twice as many people
you need twice as much employees in
stock and floor space and everything has
to be twice as much okay so like
software if I build software and I want
to serve 10 times as many people I just
onboard them yeah they have a username
and a password if I want to have a
thousand times more people I just have a
username and a password and they just
get access to the software so
um you know that is a very different
business to a burger okay business idea
I want to make the ultimate productivity
app notion and things and todoist like
they're Evernote they're all a bit like
uh they don't have they're not quite
right yep I think me as a 26 year old
Junior doctor
um with a vague background of coding you
know what I want to build the best
productivity app in the world so don't
do a productivity app
um because there's a J curve you're
gonna have to raise a bunch of money
it's going to be a performance business
but you're gonna have to raise a bunch
of money you'll lose money before you
make money anyway you can here's how you
start it yeah you would start by doing a
first up you would do a little event and
it would be an introduction to
productivity hacks and it would be 30
people on a zoom call yeah and you would
present four or five productivity hacks
and see if you can get 30 people
um and that's that's test number one
test number two is are you ready to be
more productive take the scorecard
um answer 10 questions and find out if
you could be improving your productivity
right so a three minute a three minute
productivity assessment how's your
personal productivity answer the score
app scorecard boom uh now what happens
then is if you can get 150 people to
fill that in that's a good sign doesn't
cost you much to set that up so now
you're actually getting validation and
then the third test is productivity
hacks WhatsApp group I'm going to be
doing a lot of research into
productivity
um improvements would you like to join
the productivity work um WhatsApp group
every day there'll be a productivity
idea and there'll be other people
sharing their ideas and you can share
your ideas as well
well that sounds pretty good to be
honest those three things cost you
nothing yeah right a zoom account is
free or almost free yeah a WhatsApp
group is free
um and a score app account you can have
a free 30-day trial and then it's like
29 pounds a month so we haven't spent
100 pounds yet yeah and we've hopefully
tested the idea to see whether people
are engaging we're going to reach out to
people on Instagram we're going to reach
out to people on LinkedIn we're gonna
um you know drop in on like some
communities that we're already part of
we're going to tell some people that we
already know we're going to kind of
reach out to friends and friends of
friends and just see if they want to
engage with this thing okay two things
uh first one you mentioned J curve uh
for people who may not have gotten
halfway through our previous episode uh
what is a Jayco business and why would
you advise against doing that the J
stands for the shape of the cash flow so
it stands for losing money losing money
losing money all not losing so much not
losing so much oh we're making money
we're making money we're making a lot of
money right so that's the J
so there are certain businesses that are
sales businesses that are not J curves
and then there are businesses that are
volume businesses that are typically J
curves okay sales versus volume so if
it's a sales business it's normally
making a sale of over a thousand pounds
or over a thousand dollars at a time
um so for example if I pick up the phone
and talk to you and say
um uh Ali I do Studio setups and um we
actually come in and we do all the
microphones and we do all the setup and
we actually set you up a whole podcast
studio and Video Production Studio and
we have a studio Management Service and
it's seven thousand dollars to to to do
all of this stuff for you
you say yes you sign an agreement yes I
want that and then I go away and
actually bring all the stuff and I get
all the things that I promised you and I
can literally take that agreement and
then go off and and uh get the
microphones and all that stuff that I
need after you've signed so I'm making a
sale
and then I'm fulfilling the sale and
each sale is more than a thousand
dollars so many more than a thousand
dollars because the time and effort that
it takes to make a sale
um and then the time and effort to look
after a client it needs to be over a
thousand dollars oh okay because this is
where I definitely would have gone wrong
back in the day when I was trying to
build businesses in school and at
University I could not have even
remotely imagined paying a thousand
pounds for anything yeah except maybe
like a Macbook and I would have gone for
the student discount MacBook Air Base
version for 800 quid so as to not have
to pay the thousand pounds and therefore
all of my business ideas were around
like okay if I could do this thing for a
tenor this thing 50 Quid this thing for
100 quid this thing for 120 like I'm
sort of stuck in that price pricing Zone
well here's the thing if you were to go
get a job as a doctor you'd be selling a
package called a year of employment for
forty thousand pounds yeah right so you
were selling something for forty
thousand pounds but it was a it was I
have one client the NHS and I allocate
my entire stock my time uh to this one
client so if you were to
um have uh 20 clients who you do some
sort of Health intervention with and
they all pay two grand each well now
you've got 40 Grand but it's split
between 20 clients
um so
ideally when we want to do a non-j curve
business we've got to be selling
something that's meaty we've got to be
normally selling B2B as in business to
business
so we're normally making some sort of a
sale and it's typically a solution sale
we're packaging up product Services
outcomes and we're we're selling that to
a business that wants all those things
they're going to sign up for it they're
going to sign a little agreement and
then you're going to go ahead and do all
of that and it's going to add up to at
least a thousand and mind you this could
go all the way up to tens of thousands
or Millions
um so you could actually you know sell
lots of stuff so those are sales
businesses I'll give you some examples a
financial planner normally sells
Financial Planning and then delivers it
an accountant normally sells an
accounting package An accounts
management bookkeepers sell a Year's
worth of bookkeeping as a rolling
contract business coaches might sell a
business coaching package or a life
coaching package
um so all of those would be examples of
businesses where you're not in a J curve
you're selling something up front and
then you're you know you know how much
you're going to earn and yeah the sale
comes first interesting and then the
other type is volume businesses yeah J
curve businesses this is where you have
to invest a lot of money into something
that you're going to sell little bits at
a time so for example yeah like a
productivity app so if the productivity
app is
six pounds a month yeah you're going to
have to build like let's be real if
you're going to build an app at the very
basic it's going to be 20 or 30 grand
yeah yeah like super basic and there's
people I know who built apps
yeah so most software projects end up
being hundreds of thousands to Millions
especially if they take off but granted
I do see people who start little
businesses software businesses and them
and a couple of people they work on it
and they build something for a few
thousand right so fair enough but you're
building something that's few thousand
and then you're trying to sell it for
like six bucks a month and you need you
know well you need like a thousand
people paying six dollars a month and
you've got six thousand a month and if
there's two of you working on it that's
only three grand a month you might as
well have jobs so yeah you've got to get
a lot of people and the reality of
getting thousands of people to sign up
to this is it's probably a six or seven
person team
um to manage thousands of people signing
up so you're perpetually in this kind of
J curve where you're trying to get
enough people to subscribe to this thing
or pay for this thing and it's even by
the way it's even worse if it's not
subscription if it's not recurring
Revenue like I see people saying oh I'm
gonna sell cupcakes it's a one-off sale
of 15 for a few for a thing of cup
cupcakes yeah and it's not repeat
business it's not on auto renew
um so somehow you have to make hundreds
of sales every month just to Simply keep
your kitchen cooking okay so this is a
big I think I think this is a big
firmware update for me as well because
I've never really thought of it in this
way and therefore I suspect people
listening to this haven't thought of it
in this way
game for like ages now but like still
when I think of a business what I
imagine is a productivity app or a
cupcake store or a laundromat or a
restaurant or a coffee shop or a I enjoy
making Burgers let me go and set up a
food van and 100 of these things that
come to my mind when I think business
are volume based jco businesses where
I'm selling a low ticket item and trying
to sell lots of it whereas when the
things you were describing Financial
Planning and like
that that guy it wouldn't wouldn't even
cross my mind those are businesses much
better businesses yeah yeah much better
businesses like if you have a five
thousand dollar package and you can make
four sign ups per week that's a million
dollars a year and all you have to do is
make four signups a week so to make four
sign ups a week you might only need to
talk to 20.
um and a million dollars a year pays for
quite a few stuff
so let's say you've got this five
thousand dollar package and you have a
sales person and you've got a little ads
budget and the goal is we talk to 20
people per week and we make out of 20
presentations we make four sales great
you've just made 20 grand a week times
50 weeks of the year you've got a
million dollars I've I've started having
similar conversations with you know
there's there are very various people I
know now either sort of former team
members of mine or people who used to be
in in interns here in our team who have
gone away and they're like all right
cool I wanna I wanna make it as a
freelancer and I'm like all right cool
what's what's the goal like oh man if I
could make 2K a month I'd be I'd be I'd
be absolutely like that I'd be flying
and I'm like all right cool and they'll
start off selling that time like
offering YouTube video editing as a
service for like a hundred dollars per
video it's like cool I need to do 20
videos a month to get my 2k
I don't like hang on hang on hang on
hang on like
imagine you were able to charge 2K a
month for something how many clients do
you need to make a 2K just the one just
one client it's a way easier to deal
with one client imagine you want to go
10K a month five clients five clients a
two camera that gets you to 10K a month
how would that feel and also Imagine you
didn't sell them you imagine you sold
them your team yeah so that it's
scalable so you just run around
you know signing up the clients and then
you've got an amazing team yeah yeah I
think the whole High ticket low volume
thing you know one of our friends was
over yesterday and he was he's trying to
make like 5K a month and was selling his
product for forty dollars well that's a
lot of sales that's a lot of sales yeah
and I was like that's a J curve that's a
joke exactly it's a Jayco business and
he was kind of happy because he was like
yeah I'm getting Excel every few days
through my Twitter and this kind of
stuff
and I was like okay you know
imagine I mean he's doing higher ticket
consulting stuff which is which which
takes up his time but I was challenging
him like what if you could sell a 300
product
how many sales are 300 100 product would
you need to be financially free as it
were yeah from me right and he was like
just if I could get 10 sales a
month yeah and he's like oh my god wow
here's the other thing too
it's unfortunate but a very small number
of people have a lot of money and they
are
massively underserved in most cases so
you if you look at if you look at um
wealth
the top 10 of people over 55 have three
quarters of the economy in wealth so
it's a very small percentage of older
people who have all the wealth basically
like three quarters of it 65 is the top
ten percent of baby boomers so it's all
in locked in that cookie jar so you need
to go to that cookie jar if if you want
to go and do something that involves
like proper money
um and then if you want to go to income
the top one percent of income earners
earn 163 000 in the UK 163 000 pounds
plus per uh per year and then once you
get in there the average earnings of a
top one percenter is 360 000 a year so
they're on about a grand a day 360 days
a year
um so you don't need many of those
people and they've got no time and
everything that they do is benchmarked
against what they do to create that
income so like let's say they're a
surgeon anytime they're not being a
surgeon like mowing their lawns or you
know dropping kids at school or any of
that sort of stuff they're losing money
because they can be earning a lot of
money in the thing that they're earning
a lot of money at so if you can figure
out how do I sell to people who've got
that kind of money
that's helpful
um
so a really good idea is to just start
by thinking who has the highest return
on investment
is a Ferrari an expensive car
depends who's asking good depends who's
looking at it sure so to an average
income earning person a Ferrari is a
very expensive car to a billionaire it's
just a toy it's no big deal to an
influencer who makes their money
influencing young men and that's their
like it's just their marketing budget
right it's just part of marketing
um to someone who owns a luxury car
company that rents the Ferrari out it's
capex it's just a capital expense so a
Ferrari it may or may not be an
expensive car depending on who's buying
it so when you say what's expensive it
really only comes down to who's buying
it if I said
setting up a home podcasting studio is
that expensive for 10 grand well if I'm
selling it to a kid yes if I'm selling
it to a famous YouTuber who can easily
like Leverage it then it's probably not
so it's actually really down to who's
buying so you've got to get good at
figuring out who has the most to get to
most to gain from what you can do
by the way we're still at the really
beginning I love doing it but we're yeah
we'll we we've got a long way together
yeah we might have to do part three of
the podcast
um okay hang on so
would it be fair to say that
the non-jco businesses the ones that we
that make for better business ideas for
a beginner
tend to be service businesses and the
Jacob tends to be product businesses
yeah so the real J curve has set up
costs big setup costs restaurants have
big setup costs software big setup costs
um
courses not so much but you're in
competition with everyone else who's got
a course
um so you've got to have a big brand to
to make sure that it gets cut through
um yeah I mean I had a set of cost of
three years of building a YouTube
channel before we made any money from
courses that was the J yeah so
um yeah so there's those I mean if
you're selling something like these that
you need a whole professional kitchen
um so this this would involve a
commercial kitchen contract they
probably wouldn't even take you on as a
client without a minimum three four
hundred grand worth of commitment orders
so you know anything that is a physical
product is probably a J curve business
um anything that you've got to do an
initial order of tens of thousands and
then try and move that yep um they're
all J curves
this episode is very kindly sponsored by
Shopify Shopify is great Shopify is an
easy to use all-in-one Commerce platform
that literally anyone can use to start
and grow and scale a business from zero
to like multi-billion dollars in Revenue
Shopify lets you sell basically anything
online or in person or across social
media and they power millions of
businesses in over 175 countries we've
been using Shopify for the last several
years a to sell our physical digital
product planners in the essentially
product line and we're using Shopify to
build a tech brand that we're working on
the behind the scenes and the website
and stuff as we speak again everything
powered by Shopify and it's great it
just makes the whole system so easy it
plugs into the Fulfillment options it
plugs into sort of the delivery options
it's just like so handy to have Shopify
as this all-in-one platform to manage
literally all aspects of our Commerce
business so if you're considering
starting or growing your Commerce
business then head over to shopify.com
forward slash deep dive and that URL
will let you sign up for a totally free
trial so you can try Shopify out and see
if it Vibes with you so thank you so
much Shopify for sponsoring this episode
so we're trying to think narrowing
narrowing the focus down I want to come
up with a business I area that I can
charge more than a thousand pounds or a
thousand dollars for ideally where the
person I'm targeting has a lot of money
yeah for a thousand bucks is not a lot
of money and where probably it's some
kind of service that I will do for them
yep it's something that they are
frustrated they you know it's it takes
up their time and their times more
valuable or whoever's looking after them
isn't doing a reliable job
um ah okay so that really Narrows things
down because what I was thinking oh you
know I used to play guitar back in my
youth I was like okay can I start a
business as a guitar teacher
uh yes you can but it's not going to be
a massive you're not going to sell that
for you know you might sell some courses
you could
yeah these are not the kind of
businesses I get excited about you know
these are this is a hobby hobby
businesses do you want to talk about
Hobbies or proper businesses I think
let's go proper businesses so proper
businesses we want to get to 10 000 a
month we want here's what here's what my
rule would be five sales of two grand is
it is it feasible that we can do five
sales or two grand so if we're gonna do
guitar lessons and we're not
um it would have to be that we're
signing up people for a commitment of
200 a month times 12 months and we're
doing like family guitar lessons and we
come around and we we have a guitar
teacher who comes into your house and
does the thing and it's 200 a month and
it's a minimum 12 month commitment okay
fine uh now we're in two grand packages
can we make five sales of that per month
then delivering on that well then yeah
we need guitar teachers not very
scalable we could be I don't know how
many guitar teachers are out there yeah
all right but maybe
um so but that would be the only way
that it would meet my criteria I have to
see that I can make a good 10 grand a
month there has to be a clear model a
back of a nap can spreadsheet that just
says yeah if we make this many sales
it's sensible that we could get to 10
grand a month
pretty quickly with like one or two
people like me and me and a friend we
could get to 10 grand a month yeah
damn okay and it's good to be damn it's
good to go oh that rules a bunch of
stuff out yes it does that rules out
like 99.9 of what I would consider a bit
quick business idea fantastic fantastic
because it's not going to lead anywhere
yeah yeah because remember you started
this we want to get to hundreds a month
hundreds of thousands a month I mean
yeah absolutely millions of months we
said we were going to get two in this
podcast oh my gosh okay fine so concept
concept we're in the chaos model okay
then we're doing audience right concept
audience so we said um we said the
WhatsApp group and the event and the
quiz uh the next thing is offer so the
offer is constructing an offer that is a
couple of grand and um the fourth thing
is sales so we kind of covered it so
it's concept audience offer sales
um the offer is where we present people
with either a slide deck or a brochure
um or sometimes a web page but I really
love to present it physically to people
I love to be sitting eyeball to eyeball
when I present this because I want to
see how they actually react oh wait so
you're saying I have to actually talk to
people and sell them this thing yes nah
come on that's not that's not my idea of
what a business is I thought I'd just
sit in my bedroom and make something and
then suddenly become a you become a
millionaire you eventually do uh but the
the yeah when you're starting business
you want to get close enough to lick
their face you want to be right up close
to your customers you want to see
exactly how they interact isn't that
such an old-school way of like thinking
about business surely the world has
changed surely I can just like make an
app or something yeah
um the best the best tech entrepreneurs
I know they love to get hand hands hand
really hand on with a client with a with
a potential client so in the early days
we're talking about going in stages and
stage one we just want to see how does
the person react when I tell people this
is what we've created for you would you
like to sign up and they go hmm does it
come in Blue uh yeah we can make it in
blue oh could I get it in extra large
yeah we could do it in extra large I
need it to be spaced out over six
payments can we do six payments yeah we
can do six payments okay cool yeah I
will sign up if it's blue and extra
large and six payments fantastic
um so that's what we need to do and they
won't do that online they won't actually
they won't drop you an email and say
well if it was this and this isn't is
then I would have done it they'll just
go no not for me
so you have to be you have to do at
least 30 sales meetings to get any
um data whatsoever you know you know um
because you did statistics and and
science
um statistical analysis you need 30
samples uh as like a the basics of
statistical significance
um 150 is like at next level up so I'm a
big fan that you don't judge your
product or service until you've sat down
with 30 customers and see how 30 people
respond damn okay I'm Feeling by my big
bird right now even though I've done
this business thing business thing for a
while but like yeah I just never thought
yeah so like when I launch Score app I
literally sat down with people like lots
of people I booked out a boardroom and I
just had appointment after appointment
after appointment after appointment I
spent an hour with each person
sitting down and saying we're going to
create a scorecard here's what we need
to do here's how we do it this is the
this is the kind of process and the
framework what what would it be and I
wanted to see how they would interact
with it and we would also get on the
phone and say hey we're launching these
scorecards
um they're two grand each would you like
to buy one oh well what does it do how
does it work well here's what it does
and here's how it works and we can build
these and in the early days I actually
sold them at two grand a pop
um because I wanted to just see if
people would pay a couple of grand for
them
um and and I had my team building them
on WordPress
so we were sitting down with customers
after customers after customers and we
refined it and refined it like a
blacksmith sharpening and sharpening and
sharpening we were sharpening our pitch
and we were sharpening our sales process
and we're sharpening what the product
looked like and we're just going to
right so okay I did not judge until I
had 30 30 pages of notes after every
single one to one take lots of notes
what did they like what did they not
like what did they see a value what did
they not see a value what did they get
what did they not get so like all of
that nice what did they want to do with
it what were they excited you know what
outcomes were they excited by so all of
that okay nice
okay so let's say
I'm gonna make up a random offer so
let's say I lose my everything on my
YouTube channel I get canceled overnight
but I still have the skills I'm keeping
in mind that my business ideas have to
be something I can solve for ideally 2K
ideally five sales a month I might be
thinking either
web design agency type situation
potentially but I've kind of been
outside of that market for a while or
I'd be thinking
uh video content just quickly yeah
you've been outside of that market do
you know someone who's credible web
development do you know someone who's a
web developer yeah yeah sell them
hmm yeah that could work actually in my
head was defaulting to oh I guess I'd
have to do it myself I need to learn
quite a lot of stuff no you don't you
can find someone who's good at web
development and you can just go running
around selling two grand packages for
them to build oh
okay that could work too there you go
there's 10 grand a month
what if I was like uh hey I know how to
use a camera I know how to do video
editing uh therefore if I do personal
brand video content for startup Founders
who I know have money or yeah business
owners like you who I know have money
and I could be like Dan you have books
you want to be on all the con to social
platforms I'll show up to your house
once every month and we'll film a bunch
of stuff I'll just ask you the questions
I'll chop it up content for Instagram
Facebook LinkedIn etc etc sign me up
yeah of course so that's that's a great
example yeah and um and you just sign me
up and you might say it's initially two
grand and see if you like it then it's
two grand a month after that yeah um now
you might say uh by the way I've got a
whole team I've got an amazing team of
people uh I've actually found
um I've got lead uh content uh creators
here in the UK I've also got an
international team so that we can do
um an initial style guide and some
signature content and we can also do
Brute Force content you know through our
team in the Philippines and then we've
got a team in Ghana and actually we send
all the raw footage to them and they
create lots of videos and we then put
that on Tick Tock and all that sort of
stuff we see where it sticks and bring
it all together I'm like whoa that
sounds really great so yeah that would
be you like I'm really big on the idea
of the entrepreneur's job is to be the
organizing force not to do the work so
like you keep getting into like oh I
know how to edit videos it's like it's
like that's doing the work you you're
not being an entrepreneur you're being
in a video editor so the the
entrepreneur's job is to be the
organizing Force you're the organizer I
don't know how to do anything like just
just on that I I've built multiple 10
million dollar plus companies I don't
know how to do anything
like as in I don't have any web
development skills I don't have video
editing skills I don't have design
skills I don't have any skills like I
can write all right I can write books
but and I can speak but that's it I'm an
organizing Force I'm the guy who just
organizes it I bring together talented
people and I say hey you're good at
video editing you should join my team as
a video editor and you're good at
designing you should be a part of our
team so all I'm good at is enrolling
people in stuff so the sort of person
who enjoys organizing people who enjoyed
like organizing University societies
back in the University days and like
organ bringing people together and like
keeping people entrepreneur's job is to
be the organizing Force it's not to do
the work damn
still keep on thinking it's like yeah
you know what skill do I have what what
skill can I offer that's the schooling
system that's the school system yeah
your component labor you're like which
component do I fit in it's like none
you're not in the business you're the
entrepreneur you're building the
business your job is to get really clear
about what the customer is trying to
achieve yeah and then be the organizing
Force to fill that for them
um and bring together all the people
that you might need in order to do that
so that's your first 10 grand concept
audience offer sales that's all you have
to do it's cheap to do you can do it
with Microsoft Word you can do it with
Apple Pages and Keynotes okay before we
go into the next stage let's talk about
sales so sales
sales is scary sales is a dirty word I
don't want to be a Salesman huh I feel
that like emotional response to the even
the word sales uh how how do we how do
how do I approach sales for my web
design agency or for my assuming I'm not
doing the work I'm just going out there
almost everyone's had a positive
experience with a salesperson and a
negative experience with a salesperson
but that could be true for any
profession I've had negative experiences
with bookkeepers I've had negative
experiences with lawyers I've had
negative experience with doctors fairly
um there are good doctors and bad
doctors there's people who've got
amazing bedside Manner and people who
are really not um that great so when it
comes to sales
the word that everyone says about a good
salesperson is professional they were
professional they they approached it
professionally so what does professional
mean it means that they ask great
questions they give you guided advice
they are not pushy but they also do give
guidance
um they've done their homework they've
done their research they've got great
product knowledge they listen they
understand they're trying to get on your
side to figure out what it is you
actually genuinely need and they're
making sensible recommendations so all
of those things are professionalism so
sales is a science and it's a very
valuable skill that you can use in any
profession it doesn't matter what you
are or what you do a sales skill is a
powerful skill because
sales is listening understanding and
then creating a good argument for the
right solution and being able to marry
up this is what you this is what you're
trying to achieve this is what I think
you need and here's why right so you're
creating a path of least resistance
here's the mental model you should have
with sales there is the current reality
that the person has that is their
current situation there is their desired
reality that's what they want and then
there's the obstacles and criteria that
are in the way right these are all the
things that stop them from getting what
they want and then there's you who says
this is the path of least resistance
here's what you need to do you need to
go and do this this this this and this
and that is going to get you from your
current reality to your desired reality
and it's a lot like being a doctor
so if you're a doctor you're actually
it's so similar to sales when you see
someone who's not happy with their
current reality you ask them ask them a
lot of questions what's going on all
right you ask them a load of questions
yeah and then you might say the first
thing I want to do is a diagnosis I want
to do some sort of assessment yeah right
so then you do an assessment and then
you say okay so I think I've got a
treatment plan which is just a path of
least resistance or a solution
oh okay what do I have to do well you're
gonna have to do some antibiotics but
you have to take these every day for
seven days okay what else do you need to
well you need to do this thing with this
thing okay great what else do you meant
to do well you have to stop doing this
okay great so that's the treatment plan
and essentially you are recommending a
treatment plan so in there you've you're
talking to them you're asking a lot of
questions you're doing an assessment
you're figuring out where are they now
whether they want to be what's in the
way what's stopping them and then you're
advising them about a treatment plan and
that's sales that is sales that's great
sales
I guess when I think of sales I think
the combative adversarial relationship
that I go into a used car dealership
where thinking
they're going to try and get me to spend
10K have you actually ever had that uh
like have you actually ever had a used
car salesman do that to you no I haven't
but I've I just imagine I've been yeah
I've been imagining and expecting it
like and I've been to these dealerships
with my mom and she approaches it with
that kind of if you went and bought your
Apple stuff yeah and the Apple Genius
came up and asked you like what are you
going to use it for and you know what
like what do you do and all that sort of
stuff here's what I recommend yeah was
it a positive or A negative experience
experience yeah right do you know they
do 40 minutes of sales training every
day what 40 minutes a day 40 minutes a
day oh well it's like Peloton they have
a central sales trainer who does video
uploads to the iPads they do 40 minutes
of sales training every day oh well they
do a combination of product knowledge
and they do uh Rapport building
objection handling
and they actually make suggestions as to
things you can buy right now today
that's part of their process they want
you to walk out of the store with
something
but it's positive they're professional
right they're not pushy they are making
recommendations they're trying to solve
your problem if you go in there and say
I'm a professional speaker and I like to
give talks they're going to go okay so
you use a lot of keynote yeah okay did
you know that this thing here this is
like a touch bar and it actually shows
you your slides as you're going through
and you can see your slides when you're
speaking and you can jump to slides from
slide it's like oh that I would use that
all the time yeah that's that's a really
good thing that you might want to use I
want that great
let's back it let's box it up
okay so they're doing 40 minutes of
sales training a day
right and it's a positive experience
Everyone likes Geniuses yeah but they're
sales people
okay
so it sounds like to go from zero to 10K
all we need to do is come up with some
kind of concept that we can charge
ideally 2K4 yep and find a way to land
five clients a month through a sales
process through sales process I will say
one more thing about sales you need to
learn how to do laps leads appointments
presentations sales so you just keep a
little spreadsheet who are your leads
who are the people that might buy
can you book an appointment to speak
with them right actually get their their
commitment to just focus yeah can you
present them with a solution can you
actually do a presentation or an actual
conversation
um and then can you ask them whether
they would like to go ahead or not and
those are the four steps lead
appointment presentation sales so great
sales people do a rhythm of weekly laps
they do leads appointments presentation
sales and they just have a a good good
salesperson has a dashboard digital or
physical and they just have a set of
leads appointments presentations and
sales so laps laps lap slaps laps and
entrepreneurs need to do that as well
when they're launching something
and I suspect ninety percent of people
listening to this were previously like
oh I want to be an entrepreneur it
sounds easy and now they're like you
know it's horrible you've turned me off
you know what the day job sounds pretty
sounds pretty compelling
let me be honest with you
the other day I was on the train I
bumped into a friend of mine who works
in a big job big big corporate and he's
sitting on the train reading fiction
reading a fiction book and I'm looking
at this and I'm going
wow like if I've got spare time I am not
reading a fiction book I'm like trying
to you know do some self-improvement or
I'm trying to read a book about business
but just the Casual ex you know the
Casual relaxed I'm reading a fiction
book and I'm like that must be what it
like that's what it must feel like to
have a job like to have certainty that
that level of certainty it's lovely what
a delight
for your kids would you feel a bit
disappointed if they got a real job
and not if they not if they loved it no
not at all um provided they're you know
they're enjoying it they're adding value
um like entrepreneurship is as I say
it's something you do reluctantly you do
it because you spot something in the
world that you want to bring to life you
want to do this thing and it's like you
go in eyes wide open but look I will say
this the the upside with entrepreneurs
while uh one entrepreneurship is wild if
you get it right like so 10 000 a month
is where you kind of like 10 000 a month
is where you're on par with a basic job
because you're gonna have a few
overheads so you know if you take a
basic job and you say okay four or five
grand a month like NHS uh doctor is
there would they be on about five grand
a month yeah four or five okay
so you know depending on what level but
yeah yeah so essentially that 10 grand a
month of sales minus an assistant minus
some cost of doing business is going to
leave you with about four or five grand
a month
um so if you can do that you're on par
with a job but you've got extra work
extra stress and if you stop the whole
thing stops so you're you're kind of
like just benchmarking you know those
games where there's like a a shadow
person and you're trying to keep up with
that shadow person so at 10 grand a
month you're you're kind of like neck
and neck with your employed shadow
person at that at that stage nice
um any final tips or Red Resources for
the 0 to 10K a month bracket before we
move Beyond 10K a month uh final tips or
resources so concept audience offers
sales
um
yeah I would just say just take it stay
curious be embrace the critics when
someone says they don't like it just ask
why
um you know if someone says oh I like no
I'm not at all interested in that oh
that's really that's really curious I'm
so surprised because I imagined you
would be interested in this so just
don't take anything personally you're a
scientist conducting experiments and
it's like whoa that worked well that
didn't work but don't be emotionally
invested in it you have to start the pro
the process has to begin with curiosity
of this probably won't work let's see if
it does uh you know a bunch of this I
think I've got a bunch of this right but
I've probably got a bunch wrong got it
and then final thing on this front like
this sort of thing and I I I still have
residual bits of this myself sort of
emotional feelings about money and about
how like
selling something is kind of
evil or bad or you're a bad person for
like and and I I still got these
residual narratives in my mind and in my
heart and I know rationally that like
yeah I imagine a lot of people are
having capitalism and money is the most
pure and Brilliant transaction it's the
most incredible system the
the marginal utility of a cup of coffee
for a coffee shop owner is really low
they don't want that cup of coffee right
the marginal utility of the coffee for
the person who doesn't have a cup of
coffee is high
and the marginal utility of their two
pounds 50 or the three dollars
is low so everyone wins isn't that
incredible like think about that just
for a moment the coffee shop owner is so
happy that you gave them three dollars
for the coffee you're so happy that they
have this coffee shop and that they were
just willing to give you this delicious
coffee and for three dollars and you're
like I didn't want the three dollars I
didn't care there's my three dollars yay
hot cup of coffee fantastic and and then
they're like Yay I got three dollars I
didn't need that extra cup of coffee so
this is the beauty of business that you
essentially have two people who are
super happy super stoked so
this is what every transaction involves
every single transaction that happens in
the economy is two people who felt that
they want two people felt that they
walked away going that is so great I I
paid for something that I was I'm
getting a great deal and the person who
sold it is like yay I made a sale I love
it this is capitalism and it's so
amazing it's the most incredible system
it sounds so obvious when you put it
like that but even hearing you say that
like has sort of triggered some kind of
surprise in me I was like oh yeah I've
just never considered that I just sort
of like float around thinking oh people
just buy and sell stuff and but if I'm
selling something that's bad and if
someone's buying from me then like oh
like I better make sure like I'm like
not selling them snake oil and
the palpitations start yeah so yeah of
course there's a couple of things snake
oil doesn't work and that's the problem
with it yeah right so like for example
trading courses they don't work you're
not going to beat the Traders uh you're
not going to beat the professionals so
it is snake or because it doesn't work
um if you sold a trading course to a
professional Trader to make them go from
good to great
um then it wouldn't be snake oil um if
you sell a Ferrari to someone who can
afford a Ferrari if someone sells their
company for 100 million dollars and
they've always wanted a Ferrari and it's
their childhood dream to have a Ferrari
and they've got loads of money and for
them it's just a great thing and they've
always wanted it yeah that's that's not
a thing if if I pressured someone into
getting a Ferrari and they couldn't
really afford it and I signed them up to
a payment plan that they couldn't really
afford that's a horrible thing it's
actually not the product that is the
problem it's picking who you're going to
sell to making sure that they actually
feel good about it you know you want to
and anything can be missiled anything
can be really well sold to the right
people and if you're worried about it
then you're the type of person who's
only going to sell to the right people
anyway the only people who who are bad
in the economy are the ones who don't
care yeah so by virtue of the fact that
you're worried about this means you're
one of the good actors hmm at this point
our hypothetical business is doing 10K a
month what does our team look like at
this point and then how do we go to 100K
a month you're right because that seems
like bloody hell and millionaire yeah
exactly uh you're either two to four
people at this point so 10 grand a month
is normally a two person three or four
people
um so two to four people typically
um you normally would have a salesperson
you would have someone who's like
customer service or fulfillment maybe
you've got a bookkeeper or an
administrator or an assistant
so when I started I arrived in 2006 2007
into London first thing I did is I had
an executive assistant
um and a salesperson
and a event manager because we were
running events so fulfillment so I
literally week two had three people on
the team how did you find these people
uh how did I find them I or how would
one find people these days
literally I'm launching a business and
I'm looking for some people who can help
um does anyone know anyone who's looking
for something
um yeah it's asking friends and family
and stuff just asking around most people
know someone who's looking for you're
looking for Rebels and misfits you're
looking for the wrong people not the
right people what do you mean like the
neighbor's kid or some you you know you
go to McDonald's and you see this like
like happy cheerful person who's like
wiping down tables and they're like in a
good mood and they're like wiping the
tables down and you go awesome like what
a positive attitude like you're awesome
um or you might you know just um someone
might try and knock on your door and say
hey we're in the neighborhood and we're
you know cleaning cars hey actually why
don't you come and work with me yeah
um so you're looking for the wrong
people not the right people there's no
good people who are gonna quit their job
at Microsoft and join your
random startup yeah um uni students mum
moms who uh who like have little kids in
there in daycare and they've got a few
hours or dads
um you could have uh someone who's got a
disability and just doesn't fit within a
corporate environment needs flexibility
people who've got a really thick accent
and they always get judged because their
accent's like too thick hard to
understand but they're actually really
smart and great
um so someone who's got ba bo like
really bad body odor they really smell
Rebels and misfits okay I'm actually
serious by the way they're they're
amazing people I hired this one guy once
when I was launching a business back in
like early days and he was a very very
spotty uh 19 year old and he did have
really bad Bo
um he was he was stinky and he was
amazing he was absolutely awesome
like so great
damn okay
um how why do you think he didn't have a
job
because he was smelling's body yeah so
he was a rebel and a misfit yeah
uh okay uh remote versus in person I
don't care I care about team Vibes so
team Vibes is like do we have a Monday
morning meeting do we natter right
nattering is likely we like can't stop
talking
um so if you look at my slack Channel
today everyone's nattering oh hey we
just did this we just did that oh by the
way did you hear that this happened oh
we just had this problem come in we
solved it like this
um like giffy's flying around what type
of thing
you know voice note hey I just had an
idea oh yeah what if we did it like this
hey what if we like created like a
corporate version that does this thing
right so that's nattering and it's the
excitement that's happening there's
chemistry form yeah so you can have that
remotely as well you can have that
remotely of course yeah yeah I mean as
uh score app doesn't have actually
offices we have quarterly meetings uh
where we get the whole team together and
we have um Zoom calls where we get
everyone together and we have slack
channels and WhatsApp groups and like
nuttering and all that sort of stuff we
go out to dinners together to build
chemistry but uh we are a multi-million
pound business and we don't have offices
and never have hmm
and would you sort of freelance a
part-time full-time what's the whatever
fits the business so long as they're
passionate as long as they're like in it
they're in on it they're in on the joke
yeah they get it where hey we're doing
this thing you know and how do you pitch
them the job like who's who's going to
be like hell yeah I want to sell
financial planning services for 2K a pop
like well um normally it's someone who
for them it's a step up in the early
days you're getting Rebels and misfits
so it's a step up for them it's like wow
really you want me to quit my job at
Starbucks and come and work with you
that would be amazing
um you know oh I'm a pub manager and I'm
getting like no money and and I have to
work right through till one o'clock in
the morning and you want me to work just
normal hours that would be amazing okay
yeah and like how are you assessing for
certain skills or like is it mostly
Vibes or like what's what's your
philosophy here they can breathe
in the early days genuinely I'm just
looking for anyone I can rope in okay
right now mind you I'm now an
experienced entrepreneur with a lot
behind me so I can rope in some pretty
good people yeah um so my the standard
you might see me roping in pretty
amazing talented incredible people but
I've built up to that but in the early
days it's literally anyone I can rope in
can I rope in the neighbors neighbor's
kid like as in teenager
um
no lick those stabs uh send out that
thing
um uh no I'm talking about can I like
you know the the neighbor's kid's 17
years old and doesn't have a job can I
get them to do stuff on weekends
um like I'm just trying to rope some
people in in the early days cool right
so 10K a month 10K to 100. at this point
surely we've got to stay high level plus
but like what's the what's the
philosophy here the philosophy is you
must establish yourself as key person of
influence people have to fall in love
with you as a personal brand so you've
got to be this key person of influence
you need a team normally you're building
up to about eight people at this stage
and you have to have a front person so
this is because that's what gets cut
through that's what gets you from 10
grand a month to 100 Grand a month
having cut through so the issue is is
that from 10 grand to 100 Grand a month
you can't really do one-to-one sales you
have to start engaging groups now you
could engage group through ads you could
engage groups through Affiliates or
referrals or running events or
um uh one-to-many presentations on
podcasts or something like that but
you've got to start going to groups to
do groups you need a front person
um so if we think about like
um
if we think about a consulting firm that
takes off it's because the head
consultant is freaking amazing right in
some way
um so this is where you are standing out
as key person of influence so
if we look at
Richard Branson millions of followers
virgin only has like quarter of a
million followers quarter of a million
to 400 000 depending on which platform
Branson is like orders of magnitude more
followed than virgin he's been directing
us to Virgin for decades we don't care
we like Branson Cristiano Ronaldo 500
million followers on Instagram every
single football club combined less than
200 million now these are 100 year old
institutions and one player has double
the the follow account
um if we I was just in Dubai
they're like a big billboard saying
we're opening a restaurant and it's
going to be Gordon Ramsay and um Heston
Blumenthal and it's like all these like
super chefs now they're not talking
about the building they're not talking
about the food they're not talking about
the fit out they're talking about their
person the key person of influence
you're gonna book this restaurant
because Gordon Ramsay
um so this is how humans work we we we
buy into people people love people uh
and here's a thought experiment if you
had this little business and
um well actually a great thought
experiment if you with your millions of
followers joined any business what would
happen
it would blow up
yeah yeah I guess provided was sensible
yeah like you know like take like take a
yoga studio if you said I'm now the face
of the yoga studio and I'm going to
direct everyone to that yoga studio yeah
right well it would probably double in
size very rapidly
um
if you uh like a clothing little
clothing apparel brand that was just a
business just a just a like a thing boom
it would blow up how much you do that I
should stop buying from like Lulu like
they don't need me yeah yeah well you
should do a deal with them they should
at least be sending you boxes of clothes
really yes I mean I buy 50 Quid t-shirts
every few every few weeks well anyone
who anyone who's at Lulu get in touch
yeah let me know anyone who's a gym
shark
right so yeah so this is the personal
brand experiment like you could take any
restaurant on the street if Jamie Oliver
suddenly said that's my restaurant it
would double in size straight away so uh
what happens is that the key person of
influence and by the way if you go back
to the origin story of most really
well-known Brands they have a key person
of influence Ferrari like it's Mr
Ferrari and he he drove it for the first
50 years based on his personal brand
um Fender Stratocaster guitars Mr Fender
was the guy driving that
um for those years now they've they end
up as faceless Brands but not at the
beginning yeah right so Disney drove
Disney Walt Disney drove Disney and he
was like Mr Walt Disney and he was the
personal brand Steve Jobs carried Apple
yeah he competed with IBM he competed
with everyone and everyone knew who he
was
um Bill Gates did the same for Microsoft
so these personal Brands that's what
people want
so you have to establish yourself as a
key person of influence so what does
that mean number one you're the one on
stage pitching you're the one uh doing
group work you're the one making
differentiation for the for the business
number two is publishing you've got to
publish content videos uh articles
podcasts uh blogs uh social media
content
so you've got to publish stuff uh
perfect scenario is a book
um putting a book out is a really good
key person of influence move
and giving away a thousand copies of the
book Away per year is a really great
strategy for a key person of influence
not thing not something you do at the
beginning because it's too soon
something you do once you're growing
once you're already going but now you're
a now you're a six to seven figure
business you start giving away a
thousand copies of the book and that
will actually scale you into all sorts
of platforms
um so yeah so that happens
products this is where the key person of
influence expands the product range so
you need to go from a product to several
products
hmm yeah yeah
um there's four by the way there's four
types four types of products there's
gifts things you give away for free
product for prospects things that are
designed to start the relationship core
offerings which is the main thing you do
and product for clients which is the
ongoing Journey
um so those are the four types of
products that you need to build and keep
your key person of influence will build
out the product ecosystem so if we think
of our YouTuber Academy I'm obviously
the key person of influence behind this
YouTube channel
um a bit of a Jayco business and that it
took like two years to pretty going but
then in year three when we launched our
YouTube course boom We suddenly did like
exactly 1.2 million Revenue that year
which is 100k a month yep
um and now our offerings are free is
YouTube videos yeah how to grow YouTube
channel product for Prospect is our one
dollar course yep perfect scorecard yep
um the core offering is our thousand
dollar course yep and that product for
clients is a 5K a year service yeah I
would call that actually the same core
offering so the thousand dollar is an
entry level it's kind of like um a BMW
you you've got a three series for or two
series for entry and then you've got a
you know X5 or a seven series but then
the product for clients would be the
ongoing Journey after you've taken this
so for example
um if you had a productivity app right
or if you had an ongoing support service
um it's normally a subscription so think
Peloton bike then Peloton monthly
subscription yeah um think iPhone and
then O2 selling you the minutes or
Vodafone telling you the minutes
um
so the the core product tends to be like
a transformation it's like something
changed and then the product for clients
is like maintenance or Improvement uh I
buy a BMW and then I get servicing I get
Finance I get insurance that's the
product for clients so if we think of
our web design Agency for example yeah
and so to go from where we're at 10K a
month by doing five clients at 2K pop
life is good and then me as the web
designer as well as the as the
entrepreneur behind the web design
agency yes yes I need to become a key
person of influence yeah so in the web
design world so now you're standing up
on stages and you're saying hey look we
are specialists in working with dentists
and we sponsor all the dental practices
and we're on all the dental podcasts and
we do web strategy for dentists okay all
right to do like just like web strategy
for doctors because previous origin
story I used to be a doctor decided web
design was my thing there you go okay so
we do online personal branding and web
strategy for doctors and uh where you
speak at conferences you on podcasts you
become a guest you you get out there and
you evangelize this idea that every
doctor needs a digital presence of
digital footprint you put out a book
called doctor digital
um a digital doctor and suddenly you
give away a thousand copies of digital
doctor and everyone's like oh that's a
great strategy why didn't I think of
that I needed as a doctor I should have
a personal brand that's what I need to
have so now they're like yeah that's
great Ali I love that I love the book
that you you did right yeah and and that
differentiates me from every other web
design agency in the World everyone's
coming to you for the web design so you
have a package maybe it's five grand
because doctors can afford four or five
grand and then maybe the next thing is
hosting or um uh content management
maintenance and that is 150 a month so
you spend five grand to get a digital
footprint digital presence and then 150
200 a month to maintain that or grow
that or scale that over time and now you
build out your little team and now it's
five grand plus the recurring revenue is
starting to stack up you're now making
10 sales a month 20 sales a month so you
do say four sales a week
16 sales times five grand so now it's 80
grand a month that's 12 months that's a
million okay so let's say I'm doing my
5K web design packages
at that point the Temptation would be
you know what we're really good at doing
web design for doctors why don't we also
do web design for dentists you start
targeting the dentist you could pivot
yeah you could expand into an into an
additional market so this is just
campaigning you're just you're now
campaigning for bigger markets so this
is exactly what Nike did with its shoes
um day one they were Blue Ribbon shoes
and they only did track and Fields and
they um they had a key person of
influence called Bill Bowerman Bill
Bowman was the co-founder of Nike so the
effectively
um Phil Knight was the CEO Bill Bauman
was the Visionary who wrote a book uh
that sold a million copies called
jogging and he kicked off the jogging
Revolution and he was the co-founder of
Nike and basically you read the book
called jogging and then you went to the
Blue Ribbon choose website oh no they
didn't have a website what am I talking
about you then heard about Blue Ribbon
shoes and you bought the Blue Ribbon
shoes yeah they probably had mail order
in the book yeah and um
and they actually turned up to all these
track and field events and they did all
of that now when they wanted to grow the
business they said hey what else could
we do we could do basketball who could
who's like capturing people's attention
in basketball we need a key person of
influence for that Michael Jordan so
they said let's sign this guy up
um and then they said tennis oh there
this guy called Andre Agassi let's sign
him up so they basically campaigned for
different verticals and each vertical's
got a key person of influence a face
what's the balance okay so let's make a
concrete with our YouTuber Academy for
example
um what's the balance between let me
stay in my lane and just keep on making
more products for my existing Market of
people wanting to start a YouTube
channel
versus you know what
I'm kind of known for productivity let
me start a productivity app
so people are willing to go on a journey
with you provide it it's okay to have a
product ecosystem so I wanna I want you
to think about yourself I know this will
sound strange imagine you're like the
Eiffel Tower
okay but how does the Eiffel Tower make
money actually the real money's made in
all the things around the Eiffel Tower
so when people go to hotels restaurants
cafes museums galleries that's all stuff
that's around the Eiffel Tower so people
are attracted to the Eiffel Tower but
there's all the things around the Eiffel
Tower that make all the money the I like
very few people go to Paris and drop all
their money on like a trip up to the
Eiffel Tower and back that's like yeah
15 credits no they like to be around it
they like to see it they don't you know
they don't actually expect to spend all
that much money on it yeah but this is
what a personal brand should be like a
key person of influence should be the
Eiffel Tower
and they should have a product ecosystem
around them me personally uh so I've got
the books out and I give talks and I'm
on a podcast but I actually have a
publishing company called rethink press
I've got a um Awards business and a PR
business called August I've got a
business that does Capital fundraising
um right I've got a an accelerator
business called Dent
um so there's all these businesses that
I've got I've got software business
called score app and these are all the
things that are you know kind of selling
each one has its own product ecosystem
all these products you know they they if
I'm out there talking people are going
hey what do you what do you do
um let's get involved in it
does every business have some kind of
key person of influence no most
businesses don't which is why they don't
take off
it's only a very narrow set of
businesses that take off there's
millions of there's actually millions of
businesses in the UK yeah and there's
tens of thousands that are really
profitable so like the local laundromat
does not have a key person of influence
behind it no local coffee shop probably
doesn't unless it's a James Hoffman's
coffee shop because he's like the most
famous coffee guy in the world from his
YouTube channel and now he's really rich
yeah his products are really good yeah
and he's building a Roastery he's got
his coffee brand he's got his gear he's
got his totally okay yeah he's a keeper
in the coffee and everything's booming
around him yeah yeah ah okay so Mr Who's
The Boss versus water stock company tech
companies Mr who's the boss could have a
dozen products and they could all boom
and uh you know he's got 15 million
followers so literally that is millions
that is thousands of businesses that
could do millions of dollars like you're
talking a massive Empire
um if if he wants to uh because like you
know think about this A Center Court at
Wimbledon holds 16 000 people
quite a lot you've got four and a half
million 16 000 is a rounding error yeah
you know like the the this is such a big
following that you could have multiple
businesses like you only need a few
thousand Club customers to do a minion a
seven figure business
um so if you're a key person of
influence for many millions of people
you can have multiple keeper you can
have multiple businesses
I mean I only have tens of thousands of
followers and I've got multiple
seven-figure businesses
okay so you could play much bigger
what Mr Beast he's like turned down a
billion dollars hmm he's like I'm gonna
be much bigger than that he know he he
he's figuring it out but he knows that
he has the capacity to build a
multi-billion Dollar Empire off the back
of the Mr Beast Brown hmm
okay so my web design agency I'm a come
and key person of influence yep
am I oh but because I'm doing web design
for doctors I'm not bothering going to
the web design conferences I'm going to
the doctor no you're going to the
customers you're going to the market and
you're speaking in front of them and
you're and you discover that there's a
little podcast they're all listening to
so you become a guest on there and talk
about digital strategy for doctors but
I'm not I'm not speaking and plugging my
product well you're the you're the
Eiffel Tower so you're basically saying
hey I wrote the book called
um Dr digital and um I'm a big believer
in digital products for doctors or
digital brands for doctors or personal
brands for doctors yeah and you're
talking about this and then they're
saying oh like how do we get this done
you say well I actually have an agency
you can get in touch with my agency
manager who who's gonna talk to you
about that
um okay yeah go talk to Eric Eric is
gonna have a chat with you and you can
have this great chat and Eric will tell
you what to do next
okay nice so think about it a bit like
this
you know in American football
the quarterback throws the ball to the
other players and then they score the
goals but the quarterback is like the
star of the show even though they're not
actually scoring the goals so the key
person of influence has a team and
they're out there speaking they're out
there engaging with the marketplace
being a key person of influence they're
seeing opportunities and they go take
that one team have that one team have
that one team right so they're just
throwing the opportunities like a
combine harvester
and all of these opportunities are going
into the businesses yeah and then the
businesses are thriving as a result how
does the key person of influence have
time to run all these businesses if
they're going out doing all this I think
don't run the businesses the key person
of influence has someone who runs the
businesses so here's something you
should keep in mind
um have you ever been in a Starbucks
yes Starbucks is a multi-million dollar
business it's typically run by someone
who's 24 years old
right as in the individual Starbucks
shop yeah yeah okay and they're on like
they're on like 35 Grand a year really
yeah they're on like three grand a month
oh wow so it's not that hard to find
someone who can run your business so
running a business it's not Microsoft
you're not you're not running Google
yeah you don't need a chief operating
officer yeah you just need someone who's
like able to run a bank branch or a call
center or a McDonald's or a like here's
the thing anyone anyone who can run a
pub can run your business yeah because a
pub has drunk people and people like
hooking up and having relationships a
pub is like got razor thin margins you
just do not need to be running your
business that's not what you're good at
as a key person of influence you should
be out there doing the thing that only
you can do and that is stirring up the
beehive
getting people interested getting people
excited building a Marketplace uh
connecting with your customers the the
actual running of the business should be
done by someone who can run a business
and anyone anyone who can run a pub can
run your business so I'm running I'm
running the business myself from zero to
10K and then at that point I'm like
right I need to be spending my time
doing more interesting things like as
you're at 100 Grand a month uh you're
now definitely you definitely want to
have a like a manager
um and when I say I'm out like I just
don't want to overstate like a manager
can be an executive assistant who pretty
much runs the business a manager can be
just a a general manager who'd like ex
person who did HR what does what what
are the
the skills needed to run a business like
what what does it involve uh so here's
here's what I like to think of
um Monday morning meeting getting the
whole team together everyone's got a job
to do everyone declares their three
things to six things that they're going
to do for the week as in the most
important things not micromanaging but
what are the three to six big things
you're going to do for the week
um and then
um on Friday we talk about what did we
get done what didn't we get done we keep
a dashboard so we have a dashboard of
like did we make sales did we were there
any customer complaints do we need to
solve any problems
um so those kind of things happen
and then essentially a general manager
is like doing all the little problem
solving along the way so for example
loading up payments and then the
payments go out and collections or
there's a customer who didn't pay and
they needed an email saying you need to
pay
um so that's a bit of financial control
um later on you might have a financial
controller who just does that general
manager can do that scheduling hiring if
we need to hire someone new if someone
wants to go on holiday who's going to
cover for them like all that stuff
hmm
yeah that's basically what Angus does
yeah yeah and you're and and most
importantly they know that their job is
to keep you out on the front line yeah
you have to be out there whenever we're
at a conference the whole team is happy
oh yeah no big time totally yeah because
if I I don't you didn't do a lot of how
long did you how long were you a doctor
like two years do you
different because there's not an owner
but like was there ever a big boss is
there a big like Hospital general
manager or a hospital it was like the
hospital CEO but like the doctors don't
really interact with the management
structure of the organization yeah
they're the technical technicians is
there anyone like who's like represents
like the big scary regional manager or
someone who
point is is that normally that's not
your best day at work when that person's
buzzing around um I I had an experience
for me personally where I like I worked
at McDonald's as a teenager yeah and
when the big boss was in town and when
the big boss was in the store we all
froze and we didn't work very well
um and I also worked around uh some
people who were very well known
um and when they were around everyone
froze no one worked really well yeah so
less is more when you hit a certain
point you're far better off just being
out there being this you know being the
key person of influence doing deals
raising profile doing Partnerships
finding opportunities all the all of
that stuff
um being in contact in connection with
your customers in your Marketplace uh
pitching publishing product creation
writing a book yeah
um all of that doing a podcast that is
like your high value Superstar stuff and
then the team you just need to check in
with them like me personally I kind of
check in with my teams now every like 90
days I keep an eye on the dashboard like
genuinely there was a business I just
sold for quite a lot of money
like Millions
um I owned it for about four or five
years and
um I probably spoke to the managing
director six times
in that whole time oh yeah yeah like and
and never visited
like didn't go on site I own I own
several businesses that I've never been
to like genuinely I've never been there
um as in they have an officer I've never
been
how the hell does that work
oh I bought the business and we met we
met at a we met down the road here at
this local place down the road and yeah
we did a deal and I let them get on with
it
why would you buy that business
uh because I can grow it and how can you
grow it by virtue of by being a key
person because you're the Eiffel Tower
yeah so you can be the combine officer
throwing opportunity that way it's your
opportunity to say away but I don't need
to know provided I know the person who's
running that business can handle the
opportunities yeah and can run the
business I don't need to know what
happens beyond that point right I can
see it on the I can see it on the
dashboards I can see the p l and the
balance sheet yeah
um I can see the weekly meetings are
happening we can do quarterly I can
attend a quarterly alignment session if
I want to yeah
um but so long as I have trust in my
team I don't need to be there very often
um I just need to be out and about
trying to trying to drum up opportunity
because this idea of like you know you
you own multiple businesses
feels like a stressful place to be it's
really not okay it's actually really not
um in fact I think it's easier to own
multiple businesses than uh having
um having just one because if you've got
one you obsess over it and if you've got
multiple businesses you only deal with
the stuff that needs to be yeah I obsess
over my one business yeah so if you if
you actually have multiple businesses
yeah then the team you you only have
when you have multiple businesses you
only have one opportunity which is to
hire great people and let them get on
with it yeah because if you're if you're
working on several different businesses
at once the other thing too is don't
forget a bigger business is multiple
businesses like so when you think about
when you think about Google it sounds
like one thing from the outside but it's
like loads of things Amazon is like
loads of things I mean there's like
there's hundreds of businesses in Amazon
there's the Film Production business
like doing Amazon Prime there's like the
AWS business uh there's different
regions and territories
um there's like there's in-house product
team there's an external engagement team
there's like the B2B thing there's the
fresh delivery grocery services so
they're all product teams so this is a
multiple multiple businesses that are
within a business
a much bigger business so when I when I
earn multiple businesses it's just
essentially it's just a group a group of
companies and yeah like each team is its
own team it's almost like if you if you
had multiple properties and the rent is
coming in you're just keeping an eye on
the thing on the numbers making sure
nothing seriously is going wrong pretty
much and then you don't need to worry
about it too much yeah and if you only
have one business you'll solve every
Problem by throwing your own time at it
yeah and you'll be ending up like doing
things that are not your main thing that
you do and if you have multiple
businesses you're like okay I mean the
cool thing is when you get multiple
businesses is you can actually say
it would be easier for me to buy another
business than fix this one so
you guys guys sort it out
like sort out sort out the issue because
uh and then are you not worried that
that if something goes wrong that it
will reflect badly on your brand
um yeah to a degree I am worried about
that yep I do want to make sure that the
businesses succeed for that reason yep
that's definitely a consideration
so I would you know that and that's
probably my primary worry like
reputation management if if a business
didn't succeed I want to make sure that
they do succeed for that reason yeah hmm
sounds pretty fun it is fun well it has
its moments if if multiple things go
wrong at the same time you can have a
stressful couple of weeks yeah
I feel like this is not where I I want
to be right now but I can imagine
at some at some point I'll be like you
know what I want to be more of a coach
to businesses and like just own multiple
businesses when you have multiple
businesses you are a coach to your own
business that that is very much what you
do you're the brand and you're the coach
um here's what very much could happen
for you you've got such a big brand you
could have multiple businesses that you
are an equity stakeholder in and you
play the key person of influence role so
like literally look at this table you
could contact this drinks company and
say hey I'll be the key person of
influence with this in exchange for some
equity and shares in the business hey
we'll um help promote these in exchange
for some Equity shares in the business
so you could have a portfolio of
businesses that you become a shareholder
in
um and that you evangelize those
businesses you open up opportunities
while you're roaming around having
Adventures you're saying Hey I just met
someone in Dubai who's looking for a
kombucha drinks company
um to uh to to launch in the region
um Let me let me connect you both right
so you could actually very easily
because you you've got such a great
brand going you could actually have
multiple businesses like next month
and if anyone would like that please
contact me as Ali's agent
um
okay that's so we talked about zero to
10K we've talked about sort of ten to a
hundred
at what point does the team grow to an
unmanageable level
and like what what 12 people 12. 13 13
people so 12 is manageable 13's not
thirteen thirteen how do you level that
number like that it's the last subtle
I'll be specific yeah there's there's
always uh you know there's always this
issue that with
somehow magically 12 up to 12 people can
just hold together everyone can just be
having one conversation the 13th person
splits it in two or three teams suddenly
you've got the sales team and you've got
the Ops Team and you've got the finance
team the 13th person just goes breaks it
all into into three teams so up until 12
you're just one team where just one
family it's the original crew
um and then the 13th person is ruining
things for everyone uh then it doesn't
get good again until you're about 40
people plus
um so when you're about 40 people
you've got what's called an executive
team an executive team is a CEO chief
executive officer CEO chief operations
officer CFO Finance
CMO marketing and CTO technology so
you've got those as your typical five
roles for running a bigger business on
top of that you'll have a non-executive
board member non-executive director
board member and you'll probably have a
coach right who's kind of getting or a
chairperson all right so that'll be your
almost seven people
um who are running the business right so
because that's such a big heavy weighty
team you need like 35 40 people all
performing with great assets and great
technology and great intellectual
property and all of that stuff to to
Warrant that team so the reason that you
should stop at about 12 is because once
you go past 12 you need leaders and
managers in debt and investment and this
and that and there's J curves are
unescapable and like all these all like
you now into a grown-up proper business
yeah
um and then it's not going to be viable
until you get about 40 50 people ah okay
yeah we're at 15 including me yeah so
you're with a bunch of Freelancers that
are like some semi-full-times for me a
part-time out of curiosity
have you noticed that the team's
starting to fracture off into like sub
teams yeah yeah
so it probably happened around the 13th
person
so like some people have got their
little gang over here and then yeah
we've got like our money team we've got
our con YouTube YouTube plus two editors
team yeah and I bet they have their own
little meetings yeah they do yeah yeah
so you're just on the verge now it'll be
masked in your organization because
you're very profitable you've got a huge
IP and media going on I've seen your
videos where you disclose how much
revenues and profits you do so you've
got buffer most businesses don't have
that kind of buffer you're leveraging
media out of this world
but if you are slightly less Revenue it
would actually start to be noticeable
that wait a second the overheads are
high and the profits going down and the
teams aren't coordinating themselves
very well and this team is running off
on this direction and this one's running
East and this one's running west yeah
yeah we have we have to do in-person
full week-long meetings every six weeks
to stay
connected stay connected and aligned and
do you remember back in like eight nine
ten people where it just self-organized
like it just like we didn't have to do
any of this stuff and everyone like we
had a problem so what did we do we
ordered Chinese food and everyone came
sat around a table and we solved the
problem by the time we finished dinner
yeah ish I remember it was like that at
three people when we were in person but
then when we went to six and it became
remote and different time zones
and I didn't know anything about running
business so it's just like yeah so even
at about six or seven I bet there were
times where you just got on a zoom call
everyone jumped on the zoom before and
our lady solved the problem and everyone
was like aware of it yeah and I bet it's
really hard to do that now yeah it's
really hard to do that now yeah so
you've just entered this like too big to
be small too small to be big we call
this crossing the desert it's like
you're just in this like really
frustrating time where you're not a big
business you're not a small business
um so realistically you can probably get
away with it uh because you know you've
got lots of ipita uh media to leverage
um for most people the smart decision
would be us to pull it back to 12 people
um and just recognize that we're gonna
grow the assets we're going to grow the
media we're going to keep doing what
we're really great at we're gonna say no
to some stuff but But ultimately we're a
12 person business or
you go you know what we're going to
build a massive business we're gonna get
five major YouTubers each with millions
of followers we're going to create a
YouTube cluster uh a constellation of
YouTube stars and we're going to have a
management executive management team and
we're going to bring together a whole
bunch of
um uh products and all of the YouTubers
are going to pick the products that they
want to represent yeah and we're going
to like build up build out these
businesses and it's gonna be like 40 50
person team who hit the phones and
create opportunities and the YouTubers
create the media cloud cover and then
we've got the sales team yeah I cannot
imagine anything worse than that I'm
totally excited by it right so I would
have I would have my like executive team
and our sales team and our marketing
team and we would basically say all
right we've now got a collective 20
million followers on on socials and now
we're like we've got a dozen products
and we're going to have our product
teams and our sales teams and we're
gonna really kind of coordinate this
thing into a like a 10 to 100 million
dollar business yeah screw that that's
not that's not the one yeah because it
is it's grown up right it's it's it and
it's board it's boards it's private
Equity backing yeah it's outside it's
outside influence it's outside companies
that have to buy in and stay bought in
that's the problem the problem is is
like right now you can say no to stuff
if you want to say no to stuff once you
get to a certain size
you have investors you have
um debt you have Partners joint venture
Partners so you've got all these outside
influences and you have to manage
expectations and if you screw that up
they just leave yeah and then you then
you've got 50 people overheads and and
you your business starts to spiral down
so yeah you're you you have to basically
be up for that ah
so if I'm not up for that keep it small
and manageable uh you mentioned assets
what what do you mean by assets so
um a business ultimately you know you
talk a lot about productivity
so productivity often is thought about
the way humans behave but actually a
huge amount of productivity is actually
the underlying assets so okay like a
tractor yeah like a tractor like like a
attractor as an asset that yeah so boost
your productivity yeah so if I've got a
um if I've got a big Lumberjack who's
got a little ax and I've got a 17 year
old with a chainsaw who cuts down the
tree faster yeah right so
um assets are the modern day assets are
digital assets they're either
intellectual property Media or
um software typically and they are
things that make everything run really
really well now as a thought experiment
if I had two real estate sales people
and both of them like optimize their
diary and they're like working super
hard and they're like get up and do
their cold Plunge in the morning and
like you know they've got like their
gadgets and all of that sort of stuff
they have a stand-up walking desk each
right all of that stuff is super
optimized yeah but one of them's working
in Mayfair and one of them is working in
Blackpool
okay yeah do you get what I mean yeah so
who's more productive it's going to look
like the Mayfair sales person sells
hundreds of millions of dollars worth of
real estate each each year and the
Blackpool sales person is lucky to make
a couple of Million worth of sales each
year
um because ultimately the underlying
assets are very vastly different
um so this is the same with any business
the assets of the business really do
most of the work it's mostly the product
the productivity of the business is
mostly media intellectual property and
software
um media ipn software yeah okay nice
yeah there's other assets too but those
are the big ones these days data they're
intangibles and this is the thing most
people don't even know what they are now
um Here's a thought experiment
um
a consulting firm
is going along for 15 years and then the
top consultant
writes a best-selling book it becomes
the top of the business charts and they
start speaking on four major conferences
per year
what happens to the consulting firm
right so it was the book and the cons
like the book and the thing restaurant
going along for 15 years wins a Michelin
star yeah bang Bang Yeah right yeah so
it's an intangible new asset that has
just been awarded
um so these are these are the actual
like the really big productivity
boosters are assets it's the underlying
assets IP media and Tech okay so we have
a problem right now because our 5K a
year offering
is quite heavy on customer support
because it's like a 12 months of worth
of customer support yeah and we are
finding that like
if we wanted to add more clients to that
we would have to increase capacity and
the way we increase capacity is broadly
by
where we're attempting to do it by
hiring a bunch of Freelancers who are
not technically part of the core team
that are part of like the wider team and
we're trying really hard on your advice
to avoid this desert territory where
it's like yeah
uh we're creeping into
but it sounds like
if I were to take this model yeah this
model seriously I'd be thinking
intellectual property is a method of
doing things normally it looks like a
poster or um it could be data it could
be
um a step-by-step a recipe yeah media is
we record the videos on how to do it and
software is they just punch in the
things and then the AI does it and the
software does it and it all gets done
and then if you can't solve it with IP
media and Tech
you have to solve it with people yeah
okay so a thousand dollar product which
is a purely video course is a media plus
IP asset yep and that's great we can
sell unlimited copies of that and
literally make 100 million off the back
of that based on mind without having to
hire any more people very scalable yeah
for every X number of people we add to
our accelerator package which is a 5K
offering we have to add more people
whether it's a freelancer or someone on
the team there's different ways you
could structure it so you could have a
reservoir of coaches yeah
um who are all signed up and vetted yeah
and then you have a software system that
um they pay people pay the five grand
and it includes a certain number of
credits and then the software
um when they're ready for a coaching
session one-to-one they select their
coach they allocate the credit and then
they get like automatically matched and
yeah that just works that would then be
scalable you might then say well how do
is there enough coaches uh available
probably I mean there's probably lots of
people who have a ten thousand to if you
if you knew that the person who's
coaching you at least had 10 000
subscribers yeah great yeah there's
probably plenty of people who have
gotten to ten thousand and making coach
people who are under 10 000. they only
have to be a few steps ahead yeah
um and if they're using your IP media
yeah method so that would be there you
could create an opportunity which is to
sign up as a YouTuber coach
um so you actually become a certified
licensed coach but you have to have more
than 10 000 subscribers in order to be
qualified uh certified
and then that way they've they've
already got that background and then
they train up in your methodology your
IP and then you just matchmake
so that would be another way to solve
them
yeah I've been feeling a bit like about
this because when I'm people yeah yeah
whenever whenever I have to work for
money or hire for money I'm like oh
there's there's got to be a better way
of like building an asset that makes
money while I sleep kind of thing yep
like this 5K product does not make money
while I sleep the 1K product does and
that's like really nice even though the
5K product is like five times much it's
like oh we really should have a high
priced offering and yeah or maybe it's
10 grand yeah yeah true Supply demand
yeah and also uh maybe and depending on
who it is 10 grand is not a lot 10 grand
is not a lot to certain people yeah you
know if you've already got a half a
million pound business a half a million
dollar business 10 grand okay yeah we
can do that all right maybe can we do it
in two payments yeah sure great fine
done so
um also you can have one person on your
team who's responsible for training and
who's that's their whole job is making
sure that each of those clients gets a
trainer so that you your core teams
still is 12 but one person's job is to
manage these 30 people yeah yeah that's
currently sort of the model we have
where that one person is managing our
like six other people yeah but recognize
that the real value is the IP media and
Tech
yeah the people are always very it's
very hard to make money off people
um you essentially you've got to
Arbitrage people and it's hard to
Arbitrage people
so what I mean by that is you've got to
pay them less than you charge them out
yeah so that is hard because eventually
people kind of figure out what they're
worth and they go and do that so yeah
it's the the real the real upside is
actually IP media and Tech
in most businesses nice
so how does one philosophically get from
100K to 1 million a month we're not yet
we're we're somewhere in between that
threshold yeah so this is where you go
into this bigger business you've now got
an executive team and you've got teams
of teams so it'll be hard to do that
with our team of 12 13.
yeah you're not you are an edge case and
the reason you're in Edge case is
millions of followers right so that that
puts you in a in a distinguished
category that yes you possibly could
with 12 people get to a million a month
for most businesses the well-worn path
is that you would have about 40 or 50
people at that stage so you would have
teams of teams you'd either have
functions territories products or
markets so functions is like sales Ops
you know Finance uh markets is like um
entrepreneurs uh government corporate
education right
um territories Germany France Spain
um and then products would be iPad
iPhone so you basically end up breaking
your company into products territories
functions or markets and you have teams
of teams so for example let's say you
had a city-based model that could do two
million
um per City with whatever it is you do
you open up five cities yeah now you you
know you've got 10 million
um let's say you have a two million a
year product you can you kind of hit a
ceiling with that product you launch the
second third fourth product
um so now you have web development for
dentists web development for uh doctors
web development for physiotherapists web
development for chiropractors so now you
like so he's now breaking into yeah yeah
one thing that like that continues to
surprise me is that
it seems like regardless of the business
model these numbers still sort of hold
true like it's not you know it's not
that hard to go to 10K a month uh and
it's it's easy enough to chart the part
the path there and then the process 200k
a month is also like and it seems like
like each of these different thresholds
there's like new things that need to
happen regardless of whether you have a
coffee shop or whether you have an app
or whether you have a YouTube channel
whether you have like a Consulting
business yes almost yes there are
businesses that are easier to scale yeah
so for example score app is an
incredibly easy business to scale yeah
because we have hit a threshold where
the technology is amazing it's plugged
in with AI and it does incredible things
everyone who sees it has a jaw dropping
experience they're like wow when you saw
it before and you're like that's cool
um
we're now at a position where we just
need to go into new markets and
territories so we essentially just open
up channels
if you wanted to onboard 10 000 new
clients tomorrow we could do it you know
we just need usernames and passwords for
them all that's not true for coffee
shops yeah
um so unfortunately you know we talked
about the burger the Burger Bar so you
now need to have lots of unfortunately
there are businesses that scale
exponentially and the costs stay
relatively small the costs don't scale
exponentially yep and then there are
businesses that scale and the cost scale
with the scale yeah and that is like
every few years there's someone who goes
into Child Care Centers and they like
there's some there's always some
entrepreneur who goes into Child Care
Centers and then goes bust and it
happens repeatedly again and again and
again and again I've seen it like four
times in my career someone who like gets
80 Child Care Centers and then goes bust
um and why because it's highly regulated
uh it's it's every three children needs
a carer or four children needs a carer
and you need a certain amount of space
per child so there's all these
regulations so there is no economy of
scale if you want to have 80 Child Care
Centers the costs associated are almost
80 times what one is so it's impossible
to get ahead software on the other hand
you spend half a million building
software and then it scales and you have
10 000 clients 50 000 clients but it's
not good as a first business because of
the Jacob it's a hard business just get
off the ground okay
it's a hard first business here
it's a bit of a bit of a black belt move
but worth it in the end if you can get
if you can end up in software Media or
in Tech those are the you know those are
the big big kind of scalable ones yeah
like we're sort of in the process of
building a project and also Finance
Finance scales so um doing an investment
firm or yeah raising a raising a 10
million fund is not that much harder
than raising 100 million dollar fund and
raising a billion dollar fund is not
that much harder than raising 100
million dollar fund um so you know there
are private Equity firms that have 12
people that have a billion dollars worth
of assets under management you know so
Finance scales software scales IP scales
media scales
um so in a perfect world there are
things that there there are things that
scale much better than than others
okay
so if you were me and we've got this
team 15 people we don't really want to
go much more than that and you're quite
fairly familiar with our essentially the
only product we sell is this YouTuber
themed one and I've got my productivity
themed book coming out six months from
now what would you be thinking what sort
of chess moves would you be thinking in
this in this board uh I would be going
with the ventures model so the ventures
model would be that you have a portfolio
approach so you have a YouTuber Academy
for income and that pays everyone's
bills
um and that's great and it's like a good
uh p l model profit and loss model but
then the real upside scalability is the
partnership so you do Partnerships with
Ventures so for example you find a
company that's currently doing 20
million and you apply your brand and
your contacts and your connections and
then they go up to 100 million and then
you you know you exit so an influence
for Equity model would be amazing
um a um you know you're you're extremely
well connected you've got millions of
followers they trust your judgment so it
depends upon you having good judgment
you have to be really looking at 30
opportunities before you pick one ah
okay all right so that's your job to
pick who you partner with yeah you need
to be really protective of your audience
and say hey look I'm not going to send
you a product if it's no good like if if
I recommend this drink then trust me
it's a great drink or if I recommend
this app it's a great app
um so this would be the private Equity
portfolio approach yep where you put a
value on your you put a value on that
partnership let's say you value that
partnership at half a million and you
say okay our goal is to do three of
those deals per year
um and we end up with a portfolio of
equity
um you know over the coming four or five
years we end up with a portfolio of 30
companies and as they mature and exit
you know that's another deal done and
now you you end up if you want to
advance that you could actually have
people who would invest alongside you so
you raise a deal by deal Finance or
investment team so you have your high
net worth investors who come in and you
you have a half a million worth of
influence and half a million worth of
capital and now you take a good really
substantial chunk with your investors
you charge your investors a 220 ride
along so two percent of their money plus
20 of their upside
um so for them to ride along with you
you do something like that anyway that's
all that kind of stuff that's where I
would take it
I thought I told my Marathon well I I
guess it's just because I explained it
fast yeah I mean so I was speaking to
um uh cycle Bloom who you might be
familiar with
um he came out he came over for dinner
and a podcast episode of like last month
and he's running this model and he's
also buying up businesses and taking
Equity shares and stuff and it's his
background in Investment Banking and
private Equity it's just a no-brainer
he's like yeah of course I'm going to
buy that business and get an operator to
run it and like you know just get them
to report dashboards to me and I'm like
bloody hell that sounds sounds like a
lot of work but if someone comes time
with him but yeah we're working on it we
have an agency that's launching yeah
there you go I think yep
um but if someone comes to me and says
oh you know I really want to make an
online course and it's really hard and
I'm like it's easy just like because
it's because I've done that yeah exactly
everything's easy after you've done it
yeah um for me having multiple business
I remember what it was like having one
business and I I had this friend Jeremy
Jeremy Harbor who's amazing
um and he wrote a great book called go
do deals uh Jeremy had multiple
businesses he had 13 companies at that
time and he had like a jet and you know
like houses around the world and all
this sort of stuff I just how is it how
is it you have multiple companies and
he's like honestly it's easier than
having one I'm like that makes no sense
and now I'm that dude
so yeah yeah you would be the same I I
imagine after you've done a few deals
and you're like actually this totally
I'm I'm an investor in this company uh
you know and here's how it works and
here's the dashboards I'm I'm copied in
on quarterly updates awesome
um and I bet you like do three or four
of these and you're like we could do 30
of these it would be super scalable hmm
and the whole Investments alongside if
you you would really only need one
billionaire friend
right you've probably got a billionaire
friend and you would just need that one
person to say yeah I'll like allocate
you know 10 million worth of capital
towards these deals on a deal by deal
and I'm happy with the 2 and 20 deal
so because that's the standard deal
um
so yeah yeah I'll ride along yeah great
and and it's it's you'd it'd be hard to
structure it the first time and then it
would be easy to replicate yeah
dab
that's one that's one Avenue that's
that's one Avenue you could go go down
interesting
okay
so yeah we got there we actually got
there to Millions a month yeah yeah like
because you would actually have millions
a month flying through the businesses
like
um and if you wanted to you could also
build up to Millions a month but you
don't want to
um so you consciously choose to stop but
if you had a portfolio you'd be up to
Millions a month so we actually went we
went through the Journey yeah
and the Journey's not going anywhere
really I mean right now we'll just keep
well oh no
you know we'll just keep building our
assets building the assets is fun yeah
writing books is Fun making courses is
Fun making courses that require ongoing
customer support is less fun right now
because we haven't figured out a way to
scale that in a way that doesn't add
more people to our team but certainly
making courses and then having them on
autopilot making passive income while I
sleep is really fun and keep doing that
and then yeah we've slowly started
dabbling with the whole academic yeah
yeah let me let me just sell you on the
equity thing one last thing yeah when a
business sells it normally sells for
multiples of like years worth of profit
or years worth of Revenue right so if
it's possible yeah to build a course
that does Millions yep then
theoretically it's possible to partner
with a business that does Millions yeah
and then when that business sells it
sells for like a a very low value exit
might be seven years or eight years
worth of profit in one transaction and
if it's a software company it's probably
going to sell for seven to ten times the
revenue
so if you could build a 2 million a year
SAS business you might sell that for
like you know 10 to 14 15 million uh
maybe 20 million
so like these things scale up a lot
faster than courses that's true
um if you look on the right blink and
blinker to courses because that's what I
know if you look up the rich list
there's not a lot of course creators no
but there's a lot of people who buy and
sell companies yeah
so yeah keep your keep an open mind to
it yeah you've got plenty of time up
your sleeve yeah maybe that's the next
the next game buying selling companies
we'll see that's what uh Cody Sanchez
are trying to support I was trying to
sell me on as well she's done like 26
different companies yeah she's she's
doing that and and she yeah I mean it's
worth watching and seeing how and Alex
hermosi's doing that oh yeah yeah
um what do you think about that whole
journey and does it actually start
sounding predictable because at the
beginning it's like hey like is this
actually predictable like does it sound
like it's a predictable set of steps
because I'm so close to it to me yeah
it's it's it's weird because it like
this YouTube thing that I've built I
feel isn't or isn't a real business or
it's it doesn't have the same
characteristics that one of the like
I've never had I've literally never in
my life done a sales call yeah what do
you think of real businesses
uh like well I don't know it's someone
that does a real thing uh you do a real
thing no but uh but I guess given that
I've never done a sales call in my life
to me the idea of a sales call feels
like oh that feels hard you're doing the
key person of influence role you're
creating the opportunity someone's doing
it yourself that that keep us influence
role feels really easy I'm just like
yeah someone someone's doing the sales
calls yeah so what you're doing is
creating the space for those sales calls
to happen yeah
um it's look if you go to KPMG there's
someone called a partner and the partner
opens up big relationships and then
passes them down to the analysts and all
that sort of stuff and it's the same
it's the same deal yeah you know the
Goldman Sachs guy he's out there like
signing up the company that wants to
float and then passing it to the team to
like pin it down yeah um and do do the
thing you are the key person of
influence who creates a wake of
opportunity and you've got a team who
know how to monetize that opportunity
that's the relationship that's the real
business
so you're you're doing the right thing
this is this is this is working yeah
it's working um and you you do have
you've got a team yeah you've got a
company you've got like we pay tax you
pay taxes I look at our management
accounts every month you generate media
intellectual property technology yeah
um yeah like all of these things are
proper business things
hey but I think I think breaking it down
like this definitely does make it seem
more predictable it also makes it feel
like oh okay like like you know that
that realization had at the start was
that was like ah it's not as
it's not like an easy thing of just like
oh just just learn to code and build a
software in your pajamas in your bedroom
and suddenly you're making 10K yeah it's
hard the whole thing is hard yeah but
that's but like the payback is huge yeah
like millions millions and millions you
you sell a cut if you sell a company
you earn what most people in their
entire career yeah in one hit
so like if you take someone who's on 50
Grand times
40 years what's that two million yeah so
yeah yeah and they they pay tax like
that's a career and you don't have to
sell it like a a 2 million exit is not a
big exit yeah
um so the entrepreneurship game has
upside but the downside is stress the
downside is complexity hmm the downside
is you see someone reading fiction and
you think wow I wish I could read that
you know you have bigger carrots and
bigger sticks as an entrepreneur hmm you
know what I mean like like everything
that motivates humans is carrot and
stick yeah and the sticks are bigger and
the carrots are bigger so you know
that's the that's the path and it
typically is that rough roads and smooth
and smooth roads and rough so people who
have a really nice Easy Life typically
struggle towards the end
um and people who put in the grit at the
beginning typically get a breakthrough
and then upside scalability
so you know you've got to pick pick
which hard you want
why don't you just read fiction you've
got enough money
um
because of the carrots and the sticks at
the moment I've got a software business
yeah and the upside is 100 million plus
and I can't stop thinking about building
a great company I'm really excited about
what we do
um it's a huge opportunity as a business
but it's also a fun business we we we're
building quizzes right and we're using
Ai and we're doing data and we've got
this amazing team in in um Ukraine who
if it wasn't for us they would be
enrolled in the Army and they'd be on
the front line and like you know it's
amazing that we have this camaraderie
with that team and we have like the
hopes and dreams of our like team and
and like it's a game worth playing yeah
so if I was a professional athlete yeah
look maybe I would maybe Roger Federer
reads fiction to get his mind off tennis
as a deliberate strategy because he
needs to rest his head but like most of
the time it's like how am I going to
play better tennis yeah you know
um so when you become a an entrepreneur
you just you know you there's always
something to do there's always like a
problem to solve or an opportunity
there's a new channel to open there's a
new territory to explore yeah
um so your life becomes fiction and yeah
yeah it's not about having enough money
like this whole idea like the whole idea
of having enough money is something that
you think would be like if you don't
have a lot of money you really do think
that it's about the money yeah and very
rapidly you realize like it's just a
game and once you're good at the game
you want to play the game yeah so like
why doesn't Roger Federer why did Roger
Federer quit tennis because of his knees
it's not because he had enough money
like he he had sore knees um and he was
devastated he was disappointed you know
that he couldn't keep playing like why
does Lewis Hamilton keep racing a car
because he's a race car driver that's
what he is that's what he does like he's
got a jet and he's got hundreds and
hundreds of millions
um but he's a race car driver he would
like hate not being a race car driver so
um you should interview him he'd be a
great interview he'd be a great
interview
um so like for for an entrepreneur why
do you keep running businesses because
you're an entrepreneur
that's who you are that's your identity
and you know it's like it's the game you
into
hmm
you've got enough money why don't you
stop doing YouTube videos and teaching
people stuff
yeah because I'd be depressed if I
wasn't exactly because it's not about
the money are you enjoying it yeah it's
like a fun game worth playing but at the
same time I do still want to make more
money yeah well that's because it's the
scoreboard yeah it's the score but it's
how you get the validation that you're
creating value in the world because like
if you were just giving it away you
don't know that it's creating value like
what's really creating value like
obviously you give a lot away you give a
ton of videos where I do as well I give
books away and all sorts of stuff but
the value of like the products it's like
is the product any good people are
paying for it yeah um like it's crushing
when I see someone cancel their
subscription yeah
and I'm like oh what did we do wrong
yeah like I want to rig up the I I
really do want to ring up the ring them
up and say what happened yeah why did
and I actually do sometimes people
cancel their subscription and they're
like I did not get enough leads and I
will go and have a look at what they
created and I will like message them and
say you could have tried this headline
and you could have done this
um because I want to play the game come
on
uh final thing I wanted to ask you about
um this is a bit of a personal challenge
right now or personal struggle struggle
challenge something I'm thinking about
at some point I want to you know get
married and have some kids and stuff uh
but the I like
I know that one of my core values is
freedom autonomy Independence I love
kind of the
the fact that I can if I want to just
travel anywhere in the world and go to
whatever conference and just hang out
with some YouTuber friends in Austin at
the drop of a hat and I know that
getting married and have kids and having
kids I suspect would be some sort of
trade-off between freedom and
uh commitment and investment and like
building something together and stuff
and everyone I know who is married and
has kids says that it's great it gives
you lots of long-lasting fulfillment
but it surely must come at the price of
some sort of Freedom totally so what's
that life is a series of trade-offs and
you can't get around that
um
so you're a doctor you know that
really everything in biology comes down
to uh survive and reproduce
right so why are we wired for anything
it's survival and reproduction those
those are that's basically it right
humans are survive and reproduce
creatures
um in fact not just humans everything a
rabbit is a rabbit because it's really
good at surviving and reproducing yeah
so
um everything in your psychology
everything in your hard wiring
everything in your nervous system
Everything feels good if it helps you
survive and reproduce so eating a really
good nutritious meal with lots of fat
and you know like I said a juicy steak
or something like that it hits on a
bunch of ding ding ding ding ding that's
good for survival
um when you notice a good looking person
walking past and you're like oh right
that's your survive and reproduce system
so
there's something that is so deeply
ingrained and fulfilling about having
kids that it's just like if you're
completely not spiritual but you're just
like like this is an entire
section of your nervous system that you
haven't explored yet your entire life up
until this point has been survival yeah
right so you're just running around
surviving yeah and there's this whole
other room in the house right imagine
you discovered the house has got like a
whole other wink yeah and the whole of
the wing is the reproduce ring wing
right and it's like there's so much of
your entire nervous system that is wired
for this is the greatest reason to live
this is the best thing if you're a
spiritual person you really feel like
you're passing the light on you're
passing on the torch of life you're
actually passing forward your legacy uh
if you're an atheist you might say hey
my DNA goes right back to mitochondrial
all right like my I go right back to
single-celled organisms and like there
is a unbroken chain and I'm gonna not
break that chain I'm gonna pass the life
forth
and it feels incredibly good
um so there is this part of you that
wants to reproduce and it feels great to
reproduce it like in the same way eating
does or any of that sort of stuff so I
wouldn't miss out on that
um and getting on a plane is also cool
but it's not like biologically hardwired
to feel that great yeah great now with
that said life moves in chapters
there's a chapter called single totally
unencumbered and then there's a chapter
called this couple who travel together
and we're like a great sexy couple and
we're gorgeous and traveling and Free as
a couple and we're we're loving being a
couple and then there's like the couple
with young kids chapter and then there's
the couple with teenagers and the
teenagers are off doing their own thing
and then there's the couple with you
know kids who have left so there's these
chapters that you go through and people
who cling to the last chapter they're
miserable hmm yeah
I hate to say it like it's horrible to
say but there are people who just never
move out of the chapter uh you know I've
got friends who who are still stuck in
the high school chapter like I literally
have friends in there who are in the
high schools chapter like people I went
to high school with and when I get
together they they're still talking
about stuff that happened 25 years ago
in high school it's like dude that
really was a long time ago it was five
years 25 years ago it's like who cares
what happened
um so you want to move through life in
chapters you want to say hey have I
really enjoyed this chapter am I ready
for the next chapter in this book right
am I ready for the next adventure
um so
you know you're you're
you know you're still in your 20s you
can still enjoy this chapter for a few
more years um
but it comes to an end and the next
chapter is great
nice thank you I think that's a good
place to end this um any final pieces of
uh advice or recommended resources for
anyone who's gotten to this point in the
podcast so if you've enjoyed this stuff
the books that I've written are all
about the entrepreneur Journey so
there's the key personal influence book
there's entrepreneur Revolution
um there's over subscribed there's how
to raise entrepreneurial kids
um there's scorecard marketing which is
all about like setting up your own lead
generation campaigns so I've written a
whole body of work
um pick one of those books have a read
um would be great get in touch get in
touch with my team or myself and um and
connect
um because I really feel
we're spinning around this sun and we're
on a little wet Rock and we're sharing
this journey and this experience
together and you know to me that's not
lost to me like it's a fun amazing
experience to be sharing this time and
this space with you know with with
everyone and I I love going on the
entrepreneur Journey with everyone else
nice thank you so much cheers all right
so that's it for this week's episode of
Deep dive thank you so much for watching
or listening all the links and resources
that we mentioned in the podcast are
going to be linked down in the video
description or in the show notes
depending on where you're watching or
listening to this if you're listening to
this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the iTunes
Store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full HD or 4k on
YouTube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye